This is Jocko podcast number 45 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Okay.
Yeah,
I often think,
okay
then if I were an Indian,
I would greatly prefer to cast my lot among those of my people who adhere to the
free open plains rather than submit to the confined limits of a reservation
there to be the recipient of the blessing gifts of civilization with it's vices
thrown in without stint or measure.
And that is a quote
from a book
called my life on the plains published in 1876 by a guy named general Custer who
wrote that book or it was published a few months before he died at the,
at the battle of little big horn.
But we're not going to look at that book today.
Even though that battle,
the battle of little big horn is something we'll definitely delve into.
There's a ton of lessons learned there.
You know,
a whole,
they'll all those,
all the American soldiers were killed in this one unit of general Custer's.
There was no survivors from it,
so he lost like 200 guys.
All of them,
himself included.
Andy was,
there was some survivors from some of the other companies that were along with
him.
Um,
there's guy named Major Reno and another guy named Kat and Ben Teen,
and they had people that survived in their company.
Actually a lot of their company survived,
but none of none a criminal coasters or general costs or colonel costers troops
survived.
And as I was thinking about doing that battle,
because there's so many good lessons to learn about a lot of lessons to learn
about arrogance and overconfidence and splitting forces,
they're just a really good bunch of good tactical lessons to learn from it.
And as I dove into it,
I ended up coming across another firsthand account from an Indian,
now I use the term Indian because instead of the term native American,
which is probably the the,
which is the correct nomenclature,
but in this book that,
that we're going to go over tonight,
it's from a native American who name his wooden leg.
And throughout the book he calls himself an Indian.
He calls all of his fellow native Americans Calls Molly Indians.
So you're going to hear me call them Indians,
uh,
throughout this evening.
Now
what,
what I found though is as I wanted to learn more about the battle,
I started getting into the whole native American,
what,
what they went through,
what they were like and that culture.
And so this book did a great job of kind of exploring that.
And this the Cheyenne Warrior,
like I said,
named wooden leg,
and the name of the book is wooden leg,
a warrior who fought Custer.
But like I said,
that's actually a small portion of the book,
but it gives us some good insight as to
what life was like for these native Americans back on the plains in that
transitional period where they were going from being,
living open on the planes to getting moved onto reservations and some of the
fighting that they did and how they grew up.
Now,
where this came from,
there was the author of this book who was a guy that was a doctor and served a
few months as a,
as an agency physician for the northern Cheyenne [inaudible].
So that's the tribe that was allied with the Sioux Indians and,
and they were around and part of the annihilation of,
of costume and this doctor,
Doctor Marquee actually learned the language.
And so when he was up there living on the reservation,
he would constantly ask,
you know,
hey,
did anyone fight?
Koster was any around for these battles who you can just,
just not just cost are buddies,
you know,
specifically interested in that one since it was no,
I witnessed survivors from the American side.
He wanted to find out what happened.
And as he interviewed all these different Indians eventually got to this guy
wouldn't leg.
And I'll go to the book here.
It says wooden leg became the author's favorite narrator.
It seemed that his lifetime biography should surround his special battle story
so that readers might learn what kind of people were the hostile Indians of that
day.
So this is again,
marquis was a doctor living up on the reservation and working on people and
learn the language,
communicated with them in one of his favorite old time warriors that he talked
to his,
this guy by the name of wooden leg and,
and I'll start with how he ended up with that name,
wooden leg.
And I'm going to the book this Crow Cheyenne Indian man was a wonderful traveler
on foot.
Even as a boy,
he could out walk and wear down.
Most of the young men who journeyed with him.
His capabilities in this regard,
we're so noticeable that people said his legs must be made of wood since he
never tired.
Then they fixed upon the name wooden leg.
I was also a youthful wonder in the matter of walking by the time,
and this is a wooden leg himself talking.
So he was describing someone else who was actually a relative of his and he's
talking about himself.
By the time I was 15 years old,
I could go all day following in the footsteps of my uncle wooden leg.
I was tall and gaunt and I grew taller and young.
Manhood,
friends begin jokingly to apply me the name of this endearing of during enduring
uncle who then had become a middle aged or elderly man.
I liked the name,
I liked the man who bore it and I liked the honor of comparison with him.
I told my father,
I wish to be known as a wooden leg.
It was a common custom to pass down names to junior relatives.
My father told me that when the time was right,
he would confer that new name upon me.
The time came when I was about 17 years old.
Okay.
So that's where the origin,
the origin of his name comes from and we are going to get to the part where he
actually takes the full name and that becomes his name wouldn't leg.
So,
uh,
it's uh,
after an eventful,
we'll say an eventful time period.
Yeah.
So here's some,
a little bit about being raised out there.
Again,
Cheyenne country.
When I was six years old,
I asked my father,
will you give me a horse?
Yes,
you may have any horse in mind that you want,
but you must catch him.
He gave me a raw hide lariat rope.
So there you go.
Yo,
you want a horse?
Cool.
Here's a rope.
Go catch one.
He and my mother and some other people laughed about it,
but I took the matter seriously with the Lariat looped in coiled.
I went out among the herd to search for horses belonging to my father,
so he goes out,
he finds a small pony
and eventually
he got it.
He gets it,
he captures it,
and when it quieted down,
I followed carefully along the line talking soothingly until it allowed me to
pat it's neck.
After awhile I got its mouth around the lower jaw,
the loop of the raw hide according to the old Indian way of making a bridle.
When it had calmed after this new advance,
I began to make strokes on its back.
Then I talked the long coil into my belt,
the same as I had seen men do and I climbed quickly upon the animal it Scheid
and I fell off,
but I still had my rope.
This uncoiling from my belt.
As the pony moved away,
I seized the tether and followed again.
It's guidance to the coveted mount,
more petting and soothing talk.
Another attempt at writing off again before making a third try.
I spent a time at the gentle taming procedures.
Nevertheless the Pony Scheid and then bucked after I'd mounted it,
but I grabbed its mane and stuck to my seat within a few minutes I had control.
I wrote to my father's lodge.
Yes,
that is your pony to keep.
He told me
bands of us boys went out at times on horseback to hunt wolves.
We had only bows and arrows.
We killed many wolves with arrows.
My father had given me a good bone.
A supply of air was when I was nine or 10 years old.
We were then in black hills,
countries,
country.
So I mean this is a,
I know we have,
we have people in America definitely that's still our hunting at a very young
age,
but it's pretty cool that you're six years old breaking horses and then out
hunting with bows and arrows.
By the way,
hunting wolves is awesome.
So back to the book,
my mother said to me,
we have no meat,
another boy.
And I set off to hunt.
We are about the same age,
15 years old.
We chat on a Tshirt,
leggings and moccasins,
all of Buckskin or other skin.
The leggings had no seat in them as was the Indian way of clothing.
The lower limbs.
We had no head coverings nor any mittens for our hands,
although we are accustomed to hardship.
This was a cold day for us.
We waited and wallowed through snow up to our knees and thighs,
so the again,
nowadays we got smart wool hats and Gore Tex jackets.
We just got it so easy and here you go.
You're in moccasins and you've got bare ass.
You got to bare ass.
You're just out with some leggings on just getting after it in knee deep snow,
just hardcore,
you know,
hardcore
goes a little while.
They continue this hunt and then back to the book,
a deer jumped out and started looking at us.
The first shot from my rifle brought it down.
We rushed it and cut it's throat.
We Hurley cut open the body and jammed her hands inside to get warm.
Yeah,
yeah.
The Shoshone is the crows and the Pawnees were tribes we fought most during my
time of growing up to manhood,
so this is another thing that they talked about a lot in this book is that the
the,
the native Americans were fighting each other all the time.
They were at war,
they were at war with each other and he talks about that a lot.
Back to the book,
my own youthful warrior experiences where mostly in combat against the crows and
the show Shoney's one incident out of many in this kind of warfare,
we'll show you how it was carried on.
Abandoned show,
Shoney's came at night and stole some of our horses.
We were camped on a divide between the upper part of the tongue river and the
little big horn,
snow deep and winter weather.
I was 16 old.
I went with a party of Cheyanne's who took the trail of the thieves after
traveling all day and into the night.
We found a small campus show,
Shoney's.
Most of them alarmed by their dogs had fled when we made our attack upon them.
But repeated shots kept coming from a single certain lodge.
We concentrated our assault on this lodge to Cheyenne's were killed and another
one mortally wounded before we could suppress this destructive defence white
wolf,
11 years older than I was than I was,
and yet living as my neighbor on tongue river was the brave warrior who dealt
the final blow to that Shoshone white wolf crept along the ground into the lodge
he had in his right hand,
a six shooter.
It was totally dark in there and he fumbled about the interiors seeking whomever
he might find.
His gun bumped into somebody and he pulled the trigger.
Later developments really revealed this was the only occupant of the lodge.
The victim was an old man.
He was the only Shoshone we killed in that fight so far as we could learn,
but we won the battle and got back on her horses.
We caught up the body of the old Shoshone man.
We caught off his hands,
his feet,
his head.
We ripped open his breast and belly.
I stood there and looked at his heart and liver.
We tore down the lodge,
built a bonfire of its contents and pile the remnants of the dead body upon this
bonfire.
We stayed there until nothing was left but ashes and Kohl's.
So these guys are getting after it.
They're definitely,
and what's really cool is like,
um,
I didn't want to break up,
but you know,
you've got an assault happening,
you've got an assault happening.
This is the same.
This could be a,
this could be a story about,
you know,
American soldiers going against a Taliban fighters in Afghanistan or insurgents
in Iraq were taken down a,
a small village and there's people and there's enemy in there and they're in a
building and there's concentrated fire coming from there and you get a guy that
low crawls up.
I mean this is,
this is just be,
this is just straight warfare.
I mean it's,
it's amazing how that story could translate until almost I need modern era with
when you have guns except the part where they cut off the hands in the he except
for the part where they cut off the hands,
cut off the feet,
cut off the head,
rip open the breast and the belly.
Yeah.
They've taken it to a different level right there and,
and you know,
I think it's,
did he put that in there?
I mean he's,
he's telling these stories in it.
It offers you an insight as to what their attitude was of what they were going
to do if you got captured by him or it's on
back to the book.
Little Wolf had been a big tribal chief,
the most influential one for about two years before that time and his earlier
manhood.
He was for a long time,
chosen over,
over again as the leading chief of the elk or your society.
If during any time any Cheyenne was looked upon as the bravest of man of all,
he was the man.
He was never afraid to speak the truth.
The people all believed in him.
He was a gentle and charitable man,
but if insulted to anger,
he was likely to hurt somebody in either disturbed or undisturbed mood.
Everybody knew he meant just what he said.
Okay.
He was my uncle by marriage,
one of his two wives being a sister of my father.
He used to tell me many thrilling stories both at his lodge and my father's
lodge.
I recall one in particular when he had hand to hand combat with the Shoshone,
each had a sheath knife.
They grappled and wrestled and slashed one another.
Finally,
Little Wolf Pinion,
the arms of the Shoshone threw him to the ground,
plunged upon him and stabbed him to death.
He gave me a great deal of good advice both as to warfare and as to how to carry
myself uprightly as a man among my own people.
My conduct all throughout my life has been influenced by his teachings more than
by those of any other preceptor except my own father.
So that's a little,
little wolf was the bad ass.
Little Wolf was the big bad ass and I thought it was important to kind of talk
about its characteristics.
Okay.
He spoke the truth.
People believed him.
He was gentle and charitable,
but if he was angered,
he was gonna hurt you.
So this is the guy that they choose as their leader.
Back to the book,
I think my body grew more rapidly than my mind did.
This is not uncommon for,
for for men and boys.
Yeah,
right.
Your body grows before your mind does.
Absolutely.
Back to the book.
By the time I was 18 years old,
I was the tallest men of the tribe.
I believe there were two who stood a little above me.
Both of these were killed in the great battle against the soldiers of Custer.
My friend,
the white man doctor measures me now at six feet,
two inches and weighs me at 235 pounds.
So we're talking about a big dude.
Wouldn't leg was no joke,
man.
I don't know.
Like I grew up in New England and when you go to how old houses in New England
that were built in the 17 hundreds I don't know if you know this,
but they're,
the ceilings are lower.
The doors are lower because people were shorter.
Like all people were shorter.
So can you imagine being,
you know where the average height is?
Probably five,
five and wooden leg is six two monster guy.
Yup.
So now they're,
they're east.
Talk a little bit about,
just again,
this continued on with his life,
living in black hills.
Okay.
Here we hunted the game and the enemy crows and she'll Shoney's.
And here we lived in every way,
the life of the plains Indians of those times.
It was not an idol existence.
We were busy much of the time fighting or enemies or gathering food and clothing
and sheltering skins.
Okay.
As we were camped on the lower tongue river when I was about nine years old,
one morning a Harold started to cry out.
All of our horses are gone.
Their fold,
a lively stir among the young men,
a party have them mounted on a few horses that had been overlooked by the
Raiders and hurried away on the trail of thin snow.
Help them in the late afternoon.
They caught up with the last heard,
apparently abandoned,
but after a search of the vicinity,
they discovered that somebody was in a canyon cave there.
One of the Cheyanne's crawled into the cave in an endeavor to verify the
supposition.
The verification came in the form of an Arrow that hit him in the right eye.
He quickly backed out.
Everybody bring wood.
The Cheyenne leader ordered.
They built a fire at the caves opening with blankets.
They fan the flames and the smoke into the hole.
The prisoners fanned outward and throw sticks at the fire heap to push it away,
bring more would the leader called the one sided contest went on until the two
crow Indian men burst out from the cave,
almost suffocated.
And in desperation,
the first one was beaten and stabbed to death by their surrounding Cheyanne's.
The second one got past them spraying upon one of their horses and dashed away.
The Cheyanne's pursued him.
He happened to mount a slow animal,
so it was not long before the chase developed into a beating by pony whips and
handles.
The Cro suddenly jerked his mount to a sand.
Still at the same moment.
He flashed out as sheath knife and made a vicious sideways stab.
The blade buried itself on the breast of a Cheyenne who fell dead.
The other Cheyanne's rushed upon the crow in a twinkling.
He had received many death blows from various weapons.
Somebody scalped him and they caught off his feet,
hands and head
again.
It's interesting.
Well,
what did they do?
They got a guy in a,
in a situation,
you know,
they've got him trapped in a cave.
How did it get him out of there?
Well,
what would we do nowadays?
Oh,
maybe we throw some tear gas in there.
Well,
what do they do?
Build a fire.
Smoke 'em out.
Okay.
A little bit more about the life of the Cheyanne's.
Competitive sports used to interest us.
Horse races,
foot races,
wrestling matches,
target shooting with guns or arrows tossing the arrows by hand.
Swimming,
jumping,
or other light contest were entered upon in the tribes.
Competition was usually between men representing the three warrior societies.
So inside,
so inside the tribe there was three separate warrior societies like D,
three different clubs.
Basically back to the book.
These were the elk warriors,
the crazy dog warriors,
and the Fox warriors.
If any Sioux tribe or big band camp jointly or big band jointly camp jointly
with us.
The matches were between representatives of the two tribes.
That's where made on every kind of contest.
The stakes were of guns,
ammunitions,
bows,
arrows,
blankets,
horses,
robes,
jewelry,
shirts,
leggings,
moccasins,
everything.
In the line of personal property,
the bedding always was on even terms.
Articles were piled upon a blanket matched articles in opposition to another.
The winners took all and shouted over the victory.
Okay,
so these guys were heavily involved in competition because competition makes you
better.
This reminds me of the seal teams.
Like everything in the seal teams is a competition.
I don't care what you're doing,
you get you.
Your buddy says,
hey,
you want it to go for just a mellow run on the beach?
And you're like,
yeah,
sure,
no problem.
[inaudible] you're an a,
you're throwing up from it at the end cause you're pushing each other so hard.
Every thing,
every time you get on the range,
it's a shooting contest.
Every time you go,
everything you do is you know,
you go for a skydive.
Oh,
how close did you get to the tea?
You know when you land.
So everything is a contest and that's how these guys are doing this.
What keeps them sharp?
Hmm.
Back to the book.
A good wrestler and general strong man was little Hawk and so this,
this one here,
that Little Hawk and a guy named Buffalo Hump and brave wolf,
they,
they
go round and they meet up with another tribe and they roll in and he says,
we need meat.
They announced you're drying.
Polls are too full and we think our wants can be supplied here.
Little Hawk wants to wrestle for it.
If anybody here can throw him,
we shall not take any food from this lodge.
Nobody wanted to accept this challenge.
The young men took some meat and went on to another tepee there.
They made the same kind of announcement and proposition there.
Likewise,
all the men present fear to grapple with Little Hawk and there are also the
three joking robbers help themselves from the bountiful store at the next tp.
The transaction was more complex.
After some exchange of talk,
the spokesmen of the lodge said,
big thigh is here.
He says he will wrestle you now.
I'll tell you right now,
I don't want to wrestle big thigh,
right?
No big thighs sounds like he's got some game.
The conditions of the match were agreed upon,
but two men stripped to the breach cloths,
a group of onlookers assembled the group soon became a great crowd,
big Fi and little hawk appeared equally confident.
Both of them rushed into the grapple.
They tugged and shoved and tripped.
The advantage seemed to shift back and forth.
The throng of spectators whooped and danced.
There was some partisan cheering,
but most of it was merely the expression of delight as witnessing this tribal
championship battle.
After several minutes of fierce and continuous struggling,
Little Hawk begin to weaken and wilt big five pinion,
the arms of his antagonist and bore him face downward to the ground.
God is back.
The victor sat a stride the back of the vanquished and sprinkled handfuls of
dirt upon him.
He also picked up a folded blanket nearing by nearby and use this as a soft club
and pretense at a beating into complete submission.
The defeated little hawk,
that's a legit Jujitsu match right there.
Got the,
got the back,
got the back mount,
got the submission.
Well he took it a little far with a rolled up blanket.
Yeah.
But it was still only a blanket.
He was being cool about it.
You didn't,
you know,
didn't cut his head,
hands and feet off and know that that's for sure.
So another thing that's interesting is just how they were organized and they,
and their leadership,
the way they were set up.
So here we go back to the book,
the Warrior Societies where the foundation of tribal government among the
Cheyanne's,
that is the number the members of the warrior societies elected the chiefs
who've governed the people every 10 years,
the whole tribe would get together for the special purpose of choosing 40 big
chiefs.
These 40 would then select for past chiefs or old men chiefs to serve as supreme
advisers to them.
And the tribe,
there were not any hereditary chiefs.
Among the Cheyanne's.
So that's a pretty cool system.
I liked that system.
I think I liked that system better than our system right now.
They ended up with a day they kind of elect 40 chiefs and then from those 40
chiefs,
those 40 chiefs take three more or four more to make the old men chief.
So at one point they decide that they're going to move camp,
which they do from time to time,
and they the the leaders in the morning,
they make an announcement and here it is all Cheyanne's open your ears and
listen.
Tomorrow morning we moved to tongue river.
Have your lodges down yourselves and Horses Ready.
The Fox warriors will lead us the next morning as we all prepared for the move.
The Fox warriors assembled out,
forward in the direction of the intended movement.
The old man heralded instructed them.
You are the leaders today.
Make all the people obey you,
make them stay in their proper places.
If any of them disobey our ordinary rules of travel,
you may pony whip them.
You may shoot their horses,
you may kill their dogs,
you may break their guns or their bows.
You may punish them in any way that seems to you best,
except you are not allowed to kill any Cheyenne.
That's one of the rules.
You're going to hear that throughout.
They're not allowed to kill each other no matter what,
and you know this is,
I'm kind of an iron hand way of ruling.
Hey,
if you get out of line on this road march,
we're going to do,
you're going to feel the pain so they're not going to get much resistance.
Now,
speaking of weapons,
and you'd heard him talking about breaking bows,
and this is just kind of giving you some insight on what they use for weapons.
The Arrow was the preferred weapon went on a tribal hunt in buffalo herd on a
large party.
We're joined in pursuit.
Each rider shot Arrow after Arrow into whatever animal was convenient to him
during the tunnel of the running chase.
When it ended,
he had one or two more arrows in various dead buffalo scattered over the area by
the flight of the herd.
Every man kept his own arrows and always marked in some peculiar manner near
whereby they could be identified.
So when the field was reviewed after the termination of the killing,
he could find out which buffalo he had killed or it helped to kill.
It could be learned in such instance,
which Arrow was the fatal one and which were of little or no importance.
Thus the claims to the skin and meat could be settled.
In case of a disagreement,
the chiefs decided to question gun bullets could not be distinguished from one
another.
So the guns were used only when one man was hunting alone or when a small party
of special friends haunted together.
The guns also had to have powder and lead and caps,
which we did not always have on hand.
We could make arrows or we often recovered them from the dead animals.
So that's just imagine you go to these big herd of buffaloes,
a bunch of a bunch of Indians go in there.
They're shooting them with all these digits.
Shoot every animal you see giant shooting and then eventually you find out which
ones are dead.
You check a that that Arrow's mine got him in the heart.
I get some meetings there.
That's cool.
It so other people like me and you and you know 40 other guys were shooting,
just shooting 10 arrows in there.
Eight different guys shot this one.
We all get it and then they can,
they can tell all I want to hit the heart.
So you're the main guy,
you know.
Dang.
You get the skin.
Yep.
Okay.
Other weapons spears were used by the Cheyanne's.
The long and slender points might be of metal or they might be of stone or bone.
Great care was taken in.
It's coloring in general design.
The sue had knife sticks for fighting.
These had long shafts,
the same as a spear,
but instead of the attach point,
at the end there were three blades at the shaft side.
So that's kind of a unique look and weapon.
Yeah,
I kinda sounds mad.
Maxish you know,
a long spear with three knives sticking on it.
Yeah.
Hawaiians can add that to the little differently.
Put the shark,
the shark.
So it's like,
uh,
yeah,
it's,
it's pretty dope actually.
Don't want to get hit with the sharp teeth and not
talking about a little bit of the dress.
The earrings of an Indian often indicated his tribal stock or Cheyenne ear had
but one piercing only one ring and this ring was looped directly through or
close up to the ear.
The Sioux war necklaces regularly and single strands,
Eagle feathers stuck up from the back hair of many Isu.
The number of such feathers a worn by any one man was supposed to to note the
number of enemies he had killed.
The Cheyanne's never adopted this custom.
All the best clothing was taken along with him when any warrior where to set out
in search for a conflict.
The articles were put into a special bag.
Ordinarily a beautifully braid beaded buckskin pouch,
but perhaps a rawhide one and this was slung at one side of this horse.
The bag also contained extra moccasins,
beaded moccasins,
war bonnets,
paints a mirror,
special medicine projects or anything else of this nature.
If a battle seemed about to occur,
the warriors first important preperatory act was to jerk off all his ordinary
clothing.
He then heard we got out his fine garments if you had time to do so,
he re braided his hair,
painted his face,
and his own peculiar way.
Did everything needful to prepare himself for presenting his most splendid
personal appearance.
That is,
he got himself ready to die.
Yeah.
The idea of full dress and preparation for battle comes not from a belief that
it will add to the fighting ability.
Okay.
The preparation is for death in case that should be the result of the conflict
war bonnets.
We're not worn by all warriors.
In fact,
there are only a few such distinguished men in each warrior society of our
tribe.
It was expected that one should be a student of the fighting art for several
years,
or else that he'd be an unusually app learner before he should put the crown of
eagle feathers.
Okay.
He then did so upon his own initiatives,
or perhaps because of the Commanderie urgings of his seniors.
The act made a profession of fully acquired ability in warfare,
a claim of special accomplishment in using cunning and common sense and cool
calculation coupled with the bravery attributed to all warriors.
So if you want to get that big bad ass head dress,
I thought was pretty interesting,
you give it to yourself,
you know?
Now people can tell you you should.
You deserve it,
but you,
you make the claim,
you say,
Yup,
I'm the man and it's interesting.
I'm going to read those again.
It means you have
acquired ability in warfare in using cunning,
commonsense,
cool calculation coupled with bravery.
Very,
very good definition of a warrior right
back to the book.
The wearer was supposed never to ask.
MERCI in battle if some immature young man pretended to such high standing
before it seemed to his companions that he ought to do so.
He was twitted and shamed into a his proper time.
I first put on my war bonnet when I was 33 years old,
14 years after I had quit the roaming life after a man had been accepted as a
war bonnet.
Man,
he remained so throughout his lifetime war chiefs and tribal chiefs ordinarily
were warbonnet men,
but this was not a requirement for these positions.
Pure modesty might keep the bravest and most capable fighter from making the
claim.
Also,
admittedly word the wearer of the war bonnet might not be chosen for or might
refuse all official positions.
Okay.
The head,
the feathered head piece then was not a sign of public office.
It was a token of individual and personal feeling as to his own fighting
capabilities.
Interesting.
Yeah.
It's interesting that he,
he obviously fought about the fact that some guys,
we're too humble to claim the war bonnet and he will be,
and he actually says some of the best and bravest and most capable of it.
I don't know.
I don't deserve it.
Yeah.
Which is,
which is in keeping with what we know about humility being the trait and the
most critical trade of someone's success.
And it's also interesting that some of the people that were great fighters
weren't necessarily going to be good leaders.
That's,
that's a reality.
It's a reality to this day.
It.
Here's a little bit about,
okay,
they weight the,
the,
the way they treat each other,
fighting between Cheyanne's either man or a woman.
Women was forbidden by law,
by the tribal laws.
In case of a fight,
some chief near at hand would call out warrior,
separate these fighters and whip them.
The warrior policemen on duty would respond to the call.
Abandon of them would give such punishment as seemed to them fitting.
If the fighters renewed their strife,
they might have punishment added,
might have their teepees torn down.
Their horses killed property damage done to them in some other way.
Any suitable and sufficient punishment except no policemen,
warrior nor anyone else could lawfully kill a Cheyenne Pony.
Whips either the lashes or the heavy stick handles were not customary.
Attacking weapons in a personal fight.
Cheyenne's did not use as white people do.
Not often did any two women fight.
If they did,
they merely scratched and pulled hair.
It was more of a comic show than an alarming site to see two women calling each
other.
I never heard of any Cheyenne woman killing another nor maliciously killing a
man,
nor did the men kill women.
I used to hear old people talk about a Cheyenne named wounded elk who had beaten
his wife and then shot her killing her.
I never heard of any other case like that.
The incident happened before I was born.
Okay.
Suicides were not uncommon among us.
Men shop themselves.
A women hung themselves.
Foolish ones yet do such acts.
It's interesting you says that they,
the Cheyennes did not use their fists as white people.
Do you think we're talking straight grappling?
Yeah.
Right.
No strikes.
Strikes or does he,
is he saying that they struck in a different way and company and or something?
Yeah.
That's maybe didn't want to break their hands.
It's a pretty smart move.
Again,
a little bit more culture and,
and this is one is in wrapped in a little story to you.
It's brothers found one time a wolf's den,
one of them took his lariat and crawled into the hillside cave to get pops.
He felt about in the darkness,
got the rope about a pups hind feet and dragged it out.
They knocked it in the head and he went in after another one.
This time either a pop or an old wolf bit his hand.
He retreated outside.
He got a fork stick with this projecting out in front of him.
He returned to attack upon the Wolfs,
the fork end,
the forked end gotten engaged in the hair and skin of the wolf.
That youth twisted and tugged backing out and dragging after him,
the snarling and snapping animal.
The brother stood with his rifle,
poised and ready to shoot.
Limbs of brush diverted his arm and the bullet crashed into the head of the
other boy.
The shocked and weeping brother put the dead body on a horse and took it to
their home lodge.
People flock to see and hear you killed him in anger.
Somebody accused,
no,
it was an accident.
He sobbed out and he explained how it occurred.
A group of warrior policemen went with him out to the wolf's den and there he
reversed for their observation.
All the incidents of the happening,
they became fully satisfied that he had no intention to kill his brother,
that it was truly accidental.
The youth was released with no penalty whatsoever.
Got a little blue on blue there.
Even the native Americans experience the blue on blue situations in the chaos
and confusion.
It's pretty,
you know,
you think about the two little kids crawl into a cave to kill wolves into or
wolf den.
That's awesome.
Warrior culture,
pure warrior culture.
I love it.
Now we get into,
I guess I guess you'd call it their religion,
right?
And they call it the great medicine is what is what wooden leg refers to.
And I think the best,
as I looked up and tried to research what they mean by the word medicine,
I think the closest thing I got is,
is sort of like spirit,
spirituality,
spirit,
that that's kind of the word that it means to me is I tried to figure out
exactly what it meant.
I don't know if there's a great,
but you can see from the contexts what he means by it.
Yeah.
So here we go.
Back to the book.
I made medicine for the first time when I was 17 years old and 1875 to make
medicine is to engage upon a special period of fasting,
thanksgiving,
prayer and self denial,
even of self torture.
The procedure is an entirely devotional exercise.
The purpose is to subdue the passions of the flesh and to improve the spiritual
self,
the bodily abstinence and the mental concentration upon lofty thoughts,
cleanses both the body and the soul and puts them into or keeps them in health.
Yeah.
Then the individual mind gets closer toward conformity with the mind of the
great medicine above us,
so that that's just awesome.
You know,
he's talking about fasting,
he's talking about focusing on on larger things.
He's talking about punishing yourself and and you know he's the term self
torture.
This is discipline.
Yeah.
So he goes to his medicine man,
a guy named red haired bear,
red haired bear.
I want to make medicine.
I told him how he responded,
encouraged Lee,
and that's not a question.
It's like the statement of how,
right?
How he responded.
Encourage me,
what number of days do you think you can endure?
The whole four days.
I replied confidently,
how he glowed,
I will help you.
So he's getting,
I guess that's the,
I guess that's the Max limit that they go is four straight days.
So it's four straight days,
by the way,
on your own.
No food,
no water day.
That's what the deal is.
And you bear the the elements.
You can have like a little tent,
uh,
but you're going to bear the elements
as he's preparing to do it.
Here we go.
Back to the book,
the Medicine Man painted my whole body red clay mixed into water and the dish
was used for most of the painting with the black paint.
He made first a circle about my face,
including the forehead,
the Chin and the cheeks,
black wristlets and black anklets.
We're next form on the middle of my breast,
he painted a black son on my left shoulder blade.
He put a black moon.
This is going to be a hard trial for you.
The hardest trial you've ever had.
Throughout the four days,
you will have neither food nor water.
Your desires will distress you.
Other distresses may be piled upon these.
You may retreat now and postpone it for another time if you want to do so.
What?
Say you
okay?
I dread it.
I confessed,
but I know it will not kill me.
I do not want to wait.
I want to go on right now.
I shall keep my courage from failing by fixing my thoughts upon being a good
man.
Yeah.
Legit.
Going into the,
into the ceremony a little bit here.
He is hot,
thirsty,
yet more hot and more thirsty.
I prayed particularly for the strength of body and firmness of heart to carry me
through to the end of the trial.
I loaded my pipe for a saucing smoke,
but it was not a solace.
The heat burned my already parching tongue.
I tried to sleep.
Maybe I did sleep.
I do not know.
I made attempts to meditate quietly.
I do not know whether I was actually thinking or is following dreams racing
through my mind's mind.
All I could be sure about was that I was either sitting down or lying down all
the time
and,
and by the way,
when they smoke the pipe.
Okay.
From what I could figure out,
he,
they're pretty much smoking generally tobacco with sometimes other herbs that
they sometimes would mix with the tobacco,
willow bark,
Sumac,
white sage,
just kind of other plants and herbs
back to the book.
Oh,
how lonely I was.
I loaded and lit my pipe.
No,
it was not good.
My mouth and throat,
we're burning water,
water,
but the great medicine sees me.
I kept thinking my thoughts world and chased each other rapidly in circles.
Yeah.
I dreamt that I heard the footsteps of a horse.
Hey,
wooden leg.
Yeah.
Hey,
this is the day.
Yeah.
Happiness almost filled my heart.
The only hindrance was in the thirst and the hot body.
After I'd been let out,
we smoked together.
It was a torture to my tongue,
but I did not complain.
We went then to my father's lodge in the camp.
My father called out an invitation to old men friends.
They came and sat in a circle upon the robe spread over the largest floor.
I sat with them by the side of my father.
My mother brought a bucket full of water and set it off a little distance from
me.
I suppressed a strong desire to plunge my face into it,
but I could not keep my eyes from staring at it.
Wouldn't leg you have been four days without water.
Now you may drink four sips.
I seize the sides of the bucket.
The four sips.
We're for long drawn mouthfuls.
I waited for more advice.
Wooden leg.
You have been four days without meat.
Take four sliced off bites,
one for each day of the fast.
I selected a chunk from the plate.
I stuck the end of it foreign to my mouth and with a sheath knife.
I cut it off.
I was,
the chewing was vigorous and I soon had it swallowed.
The chunk was pushed a second time into my mouth and it's end caught off there.
A third and fourth mouthful were taken in the same manner.
After a few minutes,
more meat was allowed to me then still more.
All I care to eat.
It was the best meat I ever tasted
and I talked about that the other day.
If like the recalibration of knowing what it's like to actually feel hungry and
then how good food tastes when you haven't eaten for a while.
Yeah,
it tastes good and that's what he feeling the best meet the ever days did right
there.
Boom.
Now that's one little ceremony that he went through and he did.
He does some more of that.
The second medicine experience he does was about a month after that one and he
did two days instead of four.
So it's something that you kind of,
these warriors would kind of continually keep up with.
And back to the book here for his third season of warrior discipline,
I went one morning at dawn to the top of a hill there.
I fasted,
prayed,
meditated,
and dreamed all day.
Another disciplinary means for subduing the flesh was to stand upright all day
from sunrise to sunset on a hill.
The divo d did not move during that time except to keep his face turned at all
times towards the Sun.
He might keep his eyes closed or shaded.
But as countenance had to be presented ever towards the veteran rated token of
the great medicines existence,
he prayed or otherwise kept his thoughts fixed on a high plane.
This system of self denial was varied by attitude taken.
One might stand all day or sit in one position all day or lie down during all
the time.
But the attitude assumed at the beginning must be kept to the end.
My all day supplications were made while sitting down,
standing upright in water from sunrise to sunset was one way of putting the body
under the rule of the spirit.
The water had to be into up to the neck or the upper breast,
not any drink of it was taken.
It was not permissible to move the body except for keeping the face towards the
sun.
So just go get in the water and you know these guys are in.
But you know these guys are in Montana,
right?
Right there in Montana.
Just Fyi,
I don't care if it's the middle of the summer,
the water and Montana is cold.
It's not cold.
No,
it's not.
Cool.
And it's also interesting that you all different military units do this kind of
stuff.
You know,
just going out and standing at attention,
which they make you do in the military,
which is when you're standing,
you know,
are wrecked with your hands at your side,
you're not allowed to move you that for hours and hours and hours.
It's interesting.
It's like that's,
that's not just a coincidence is it?
You know what I mean?
There is a discipline there.
There's a discipline of the body in doing that and it puts you in touch with
your soul.
You stand there long enough and then like I going through seal training,
you know,
you don't think you spend some time neck deep in water.
Just dissuading indeed gold and enduring.
Absolutely man.
Yoga can kind of be that,
you know,
like certain poses.
I mean to compare that as far as the magnitudes different.
But yes,
definitely do that.
You ever did like wall sits?
Yeah.
That's another one man where it feels physical,
physical,
but at the end of the day it's mental.
Yup.
Like you just want to be okay,
I'm done.
But the thing you don't,
you can endure it,
but it's a lot man.
Yeah,
the wall sits are painful after awhile.
And then he goes on to say the bodily torture incident to the full standard.
Great medicine dance.
What the white people call the sun dance was the most severe test of hardy hood.
So it was looked upon as the highest form of self scourging.
I never undertook this extreme step.
So the Sundance,
if you don't know anything about that,
it's like all all multiday fast with physical exertion,
with
borderlines self towards like didn't do piercings and slay the skin open.
I mean it's,
it's hardcore and,
and it got banned for a while and it will no one,
uh,
the natives don't want people to like watch it or record it because it's their
own personal thing.
So anyways,
you can probably do more research on,
it's called the sun dance,
but they do all kinds of really,
really hardcore stuff.
It's,
it's just,
you know,
some,
devastating hard stuff to go through that hardens.
You're so loved.
And then
is the one more interesting thing here.
Back to the book,
the face painting as it was done for me by red haired beard bear at my first
medicine making was adopted as my fixed mode of battle preparation.
In this regard.
It was a black ring about my face,
including lower forehead,
chin,
and cheeks in its circle.
All of the surface enclosed in that circle was painted yellow.
I kept at all times right at hand a supply of charcoal and yellow clay paint.
It did not take long for me to apply them when an occasion for their need might
come with this preparation with my best clothing,
my shield,
my eagle wing bone whistle,
myself and my horse protected by the grass seed medicine.
I was almost fearless.
I was not entirely so,
but almost in every time of danger I tried to keep myself thinking the great
medicine sees me.
Now.
Um,
there's a,
there's a note,
a historical note that's written now.
It's going out of the out of wooden legs voice and it's going into a doctor
marquee,
the translator,
and he's going to put a little note here and I'm going to read it back to the
book.
In December,
1875 pursuant to our governmental policy,
General Sherman then commander in chief of the United States army issued an
important general order.
He proclaimed that all Indians found off the reservations after the last day of
January,
1876 would be regarded as hostels to be fought by military forces.
It being evident that not many of the Dakota roamers in Montana would return to
reservations until they were forced to do so.
Bodies of soldiers were set in motion for seeking out and driving these wanders
back within their assigned territorial bounds.
The active military field leaders in this campaign war Brigadier General Terry
Brigadier General Crook,
Colonel Gibbon,
and Lieutenant Colonel Custer.
Each of these four officers had been prevented.
Major General of volunteers during the civil war and what that prevented means
that it's like you get a temporary promotion to fill a billet,
but you're not getting paid for it and then after it you get put back.
But the contracting of the army after the war set each of them back to a lower
ranking.
Terry had infantry from fort rice and Custer's seventh cavalry from Fort
Lincoln.
Dakota truck had a force of cavalry and infantry at Fort Fetterman,
Wyoming gave it,
had infantry from Fort Shaw and cavalry from Fort Ellis,
Montana.
From there,
three basic points in Dakota and Wyoming and Montana.
The three bodies of soldiers move towards a common central area between powder,
between the powder in big Horn rivers in Montana where the Indians being sought
were roaming.
The details of these military movements are too extensive for review here.
The most thrilling phase of the campaign began when Custer and his seventh
cavalry set off up Rosebud Valley to follow a recent Indian trail.
The result of this subsidiary proceeding was the supreme tragedy in the annals
of our American front to your warfare.
And of course that was the battle of little big horn.
Now,
like I like it,
like you just stated,
you had these groups and they're out in the plains and there I guess tracking
each other,
or at least the,
the soldiers,
the US soldiers,
the calvary or tracking the Indians.
And here we go back to the book,
and this is back to the voice of our man wouldn't leg.
We found the soldiers about seven or eight o'clock in the morning.
I believe we'd slept only a little.
Our horses were very tired,
so we did not hurry our attack.
But always in such cases there are eager or foolish ones who begin to soon,
not long after we arrived there was fighting on the hillsides and all the little
valley where the soldier camp in this early fighting,
one of the young Cheyenne foolishly charged to foreign,
some Indians belonging to the soldiers got after him.
So I'm gonna read that again
in this early fighting one young Cheyenne foolishly charged too far and some
Indians belonging to the soldiers got after him.
So you have this whole,
this whole war is there's,
there's Indians or native Americans that are on both sides.
Yeah.
There's native Americans that are working with the,
with the u s cavalry and the,
and the soldiers.
And then they're fighting against other native American tribes.
Yeah.
So back to the book,
they shot and crippled his horse.
I and some other Cheyanne's drove back the pursuers.
I took the young man behind me on my horse,
and we hurried a way to the main body of our warriors.
Jack Red Cloud,
the son of an of the old Ogallala chief red cloud was wearing a war bonnet.
His horse was killed according to the Indian way.
In such case,
the warrior was supposed to stop and take off the bridal from his killed horse
to show how cool he could conduct himself.
But young red cloud forgot to do this.
He went running as soon as it's horse fell.
Three crows on horseback,
followed him lash team with their pony whips and jerked off and kept his war
bonnet.
They did not try to kill him.
They only teased him telling him he was a boy and not not to be worrying a war
bonnet.
Some of his two friends interfered and the crows went away.
The sue told us that young red cloud crying and ask him for mercy from the
crows.
He was my same age,
18 years old,
white wolf,
a Cheyenne,
almost 30 years old,
how to repeating rifle and drawing his weapon from its scabbard at his left
side.
It was accidentally just discharged.
The bullet broke his left five bone.
He finally recovered and is and is yet living and this was in 1930 he still
limps on account of that accident,
a wound.
Those are two just little.
First of all,
you know young red cloud who was wearing a war bonnet any and he's supposed to
show how cool he is if his horse gets shot and take that bridal with you.
He,
he did not do that.
Yeah.
And then again,
this is an accidental discharge,
which it does happen occasionally.
It's really bad to have accidental discharge,
obviously,
especially when you shoot yourself in the leg.
Horrible.
So they stay,
they continue moving around and they start to move towards little big horn.
This,
this river,
and back to the book,
six Apropos Arapaho men came to the Cheyenne camp while we were at this place.
They said they were afraid of soldiers as they had killed a white man on powder
river.
And so now you start to get,
and I'm,
I'm again,
I'm kind of a moving quickly right now,
but there's now multiple tribes are starting to come together in this,
in this location.
Multiple tribes.
Each back to the book,
each tribe operated its own internal government.
The same as if it were entirely separated from the others.
The chiefs of the different tribes met together as equals.
There was only one who's considered as being above all others.
This was sitting bull.
He was recognized as the one old man chief of all the camps combined.
Almost all of our northern Cheyenne tribe were with us on Ligal.
Little Big Horn.
Only a few of our 40 big chiefs were were absent.
And this is,
this is interesting because there's a lot of controversy about how many Indians
were there and he,
and some people say that wasn't that many.
He saying all of them,
he seen all,
at least all the Cheyanne's were there and there was more than just the
Cheyenne.
So there had to be a bunch of them,
a bunch of them there.
Now we get into it,
some of these different
tribes and chiefs that were there,
the principal chiefs of the various camps were for the,
for the home cook.
Papa's was sitting bull,
the Ogallala,
Lowe's was crazy horse,
which we all have heard a crazy horse.
The mini cars,
you was lame deer.
Another tribe called arrows all gone and they had an important chief called
Hump,
knows there was the black feet,
which,
which wouldn't leg didn't know who's their chief.
And then you had the cha,
the Cheyanne's.
So there's a bunch,
I mean a massive number of native American warriors
talking about their armor mint back to the book.
Guns were not plentiful among us.
Most of our hunting had been with bows and arrows of the Cheyanne's,
two moons and White Wolf.
Each had a repeating rifle.
Some others had single shot breech loading rifles,
but there was not much ammunition for the good guns.
So you there,
they're mostly using bone arrows,
right?
That's,
that's Kinda what they have.
And at one point they kind of take their horses and they put 'em out to graze
and they think that they had a little,
they had gotten a little scrap with the soldiers and they kind of walked them.
Not Bad,
but they just sort of beat him and it seemed like the soldiers retreated and so
they put their soldiers out.
I mean they put their horses out to pasture and it seems like things are going
pretty mellow.
And I'll go back to the book.
I had no thought then of any fighting to be done in the near future.
We driven away the soldiers on the upper rows bed seven days ago.
It seemed likely they would be gone a long time before they would trouble us
again.
My mind was occupied mostly by such thoughts as regularly are uppermost in the
minds of young men.
I was 18 years old and I like girls.
That night we had a dance.
It was an entirely social affair for young people,
not ceremony,
not a ceremonial or war dance.
So here is,
they've kind of gotten a scrap seven days ago.
They feel like they're pretty safe.
They put their horses out to pasture and then he starts thinking about the
ladies,
right.
And they basically party through the whole night.
Back to the book.
At the first sign of dawn,
the dance ended and then him and his brother,
they,
they kind of take off and they go down by the river and fall asleep and that's
the end of their night.
Back to the book in my sleep,
I dreamed that a great crowd of people were making lots of noise.
Something in the noise startled me.
I found myself wide awake sitting up and listening,
my brother to awaken and we both jumped to our feet.
A great commotion was going on among the camps.
We heard shooting.
We hurried across.
We hurried out from the trees.
So we might see as well as hear the shooting was somewhere at the upper part of
the camp circles.
It looked as if all the Indians were there.
There were running away toward the hills to the westward or down toward our end
of the village.
Women were screaming and men were letting out war cries through it all.
We could hear old men calling.
Soldiers are here.
Young men go out and fight them.
Okay,
so there they go.
They thought they were peaceful,
but they're about to get it on.
And as he talked about before,
what does he do to prepare for battle?
He,
we go back to the book.
I jerked off my ordinary clothing.
I jerked on a pair of new breaches that had been given to me by another sue.
I had a good cloth shirt and I put it on my old moccasins were kicked off in a
pair of beaded moccasins,
substituted for them.
My father strapped a blanket upon my horse and arrange my raw hide Lyria into a
bridle.
He stood holding my mouth,
hurry.
He urged me.
I was hurting,
but I was not yet ready.
I got my paints in my little mirror.
I,
the blue black circle soon appeared around my face.
The red and yellow colorings were applied on all skin of the inns inside the
circle.
I comb my hair.
It properly should have been oiled and braided neatly,
but my father was again saying hurry,
so I just looped a buckskin thong about it and tied it up close to the back of
my head to float loose.
From there,
my bullets caps and powder horn put me into full readiness.
In a moment afterward,
I was on my horse going as fast as I could run to where all the rest of the
young men were going.
My brother had already gone.
He got his horse before I got mine and his dressing was only a buck strings
shirt fringe with crow Indian hair.
The hair had been taking from a cro and a past battle with them.
The air was so full of dust,
I could not see where to go,
but it was not needful that I see that far.
I kept my horse headed in the direction of movement by the crowd of Indians on
horseback.
I was led out and around and a far beyond the camp circle.
Many hundreds of Indians on horseback word day,
dashing to and fro in front of the soldiers.
The soldiers were on level ground.
The soldiers were on the level valley ground and we're shooting with rifles.
Not many bullets were being sent back at them,
but thousands of arrows were falling among them.
I went with a throng of sue until we got beyond the behind the white men.
So you got a flight going on and they're starting to surround the white men.
By this time though,
they had mounted their horses and we're hiding themselves and the timber,
a band of Indians were there with the soldiers.
Okay?
It appeared they were cro or show,
Shoney's.
Most of the Indians had fled back up the valley somewhere across east of the
river and we're riding away over beyond the hills.
So there you go.
This is what happens.
You wake is woken up and gets his war gear on and he's going into battle.
And interestingly,
you know,
he talks about there's other Indians that they're fighting the crows and
Shoshone is,
it sounds like most of them are baling.
Okay.
Back to the book.
Are Indian crowded down toward the timber?
Where were the soldiers?
More and more of our people kept coming.
Almost all of them were sue.
There were only a few Cheyanne's arrows were showered into the timber.
Bullets whistled out of the s out toward the Sioux and Cheyenne [inaudible],
but we stayed far back while we extended our curve line further and further
around the big grove of trees.
So they're in circling them.
Some dead soldiers had been left among the grass and sage brush where they,
at first us,
it seemed to me the remainder of them would not live many hours longer.
Sue were creeping forward to set fire to the timber.
You're going to set fire to the woods that they're hiding in back to the book.
Suddenly the hidden soldiers came tearing out on horseback from the wood.
I was around on that side where they came out.
I world my horse around and lashed it into a dash to escape from them all.
All others of my companions did the same,
but we soon discovered that they were not following us.
They were running away from us.
They were going as fast as they're tired.
Horses could carry them across the open valley space and toward the river.
We stopped,
looked a moment and then we whipped our ponies and swift pursuit,
a great form of frong of sued.
We're also coming after them.
My distant position put me among the leaders in the chase.
The soldiers horses move slowly as if they were tired.
Ours were very lively.
We gained rapidly on them.
I fired four shots with my six shooter.
I do not know whether any of my bullets did harm.
I saw sue put an Arrow into the back of a soldier's head.
Another arrow went down into his shoulder.
He tumbled from his horse to the ground.
Others felt dead either from arrows or stabbings or jabbing firm or blows from
war.
Clubs of the Su horses,
limped or stat limped or staggered are sprawled out.
Dead or dying are war,
cries and war.
Songs were mingled with the many during calls such as your only boys.
You ought not to be fighting.
We whipped you and Rosebud.
You should have brought more crows are sure Shoney's with you to do.
You're fighting
little burden.
I were after one certain soldier,
little bird was wearing a trailing warbonnet.
He was.
He was at the right and I was at the left of the fleeing man.
We were lashing him and his horse with our pony whips.
It seemed not brave to shoot him besides,
I did not want to waste any of my bullets.
He pointed back to his revolver.
He pointed back his revolver though and sent a bullet into little birds thigh.
Immediately I whacked the white man fighter on his head with a heavy elk horn
handle of my pony whip.
The blow dazed him.
I seized the rifle strapped on his back.
I wrenched it to the ground at Gretsch to it and Greg drag the looping strap
over his head.
As I was getting possession of this weapon,
he fell to the ground.
I did not harm him further.
I do not know what became of him.
Okay.
The jam of oncoming Indian swept me on,
but I now had a good soldier rifle,
yet I had not any cartridges for it.
Three soldiers on horses got separated from the others and started it up the
valley and the direction from where they had come.
Three Cheyanne's,
she sun bear,
Eagle tail feather and little son joined some sue in pursuit of the three white
men.
The Cheyennes told afterward about the outcome of this pursuit.
One of the soldiers turned his horse eastward toward the river and escaped into
the timber.
The other two kept on southward of these two.
One went off to the right up a small gulch to the top of the bench.
There he was caught and killed the remaining one road on toward the mouth of
Reno Creek.
As he neared that point,
he swerved to the right.
He made a circle upon the valley and returned to the timber just across west
from the mouth of Reno Creek.
Here he dismounted from his exhausted horse and got himself into the bush.
The Sioux and Cheyenne surrounded him and killed him.
They told that he fought bravely till his last making use of his six shooter,
a war bonnet.
Indian belonging with soldiers was chased by crooked nose,
a Cheyenne and some other Su.
The chase was a foot across a wet SLU and into some timber northward from where
the soldiers had been hidden in a few minutes after many exchanges of shots,
after much dodging and shifting of position,
the enemy Indian was killed there.
Just a crazy fight.
I mean,
this is like stuff that you see in,
in,
in uh,
western movies and people pulling each other off of horses,
shooting people in the head with bow and Arrow from horse.
That's just crazy and brutal and it,
and I'll tell you there's some really good accounts and I started to go down
this road.
So if anybody that's listening is a,
is a student of the battle of little big horn,
there's um,
you know,
lots of different stories about it and there's also some really detailed
accounts.
And I started trying to pull out and match up what was happening in this account
with other accounts,
really historically accurate documented accounts.
And as I started to do that,
I said,
Nah,
I'm not going to go down this road of trying to figure out exactly which
situation he's talking about.
There was multiple small battles out there.
There was,
like I said,
Reno and BA and Ben teen who survived with their soldiers and they made
maneuvers.
And a lot of people blame them.
Some people don't blame them,
you know,
some people say that they should have gone to help.
Some people say that they didn't have a chance.
There's all kinds of those things.
And as I started to try and figure out,
which was which,
I said,
you know what?
I'm not going to go that deep into this account.
What's important about this account to me is the reality of the ground combat.
That's what,
that's what I'm interested in in this account,
and I'm sure maybe
at some point in my life when I have more time,
I would love to marry up the two and say,
oh,
he must've been in this situation and this must've been this person,
and this must've been this maneuver.
He must've seen this maneuver from the,
from the cavalry.
It'd be fun to do that,
especially go out and walk the ground and do it.
That would be really good.
But anyways,
if you're a person that's fully into this,
I'm not going down that road right now.
Okay.
But I will go back to the book,
right?
Yeah.
Another enemy Indian was behind a little sage brush,
Nolan shooting at us.
His shots were returned.
I and some others went around and got behind him.
See this,
I'll tell you what wooden legs all about flanking people.
You notice that he's just flanking people all over the place.
Hmm.
I and some others went around and got behind him.
We dismounted and crept toward him.
As we came close upon up to him,
he fell.
A bullet had hit him.
He raised himself up though and swung his rifle around toward us.
We rushed upon him.
I crashed a blow of my rifle barrel upon his head,
others beat and stabbed him to death.
I also got his gun.
It was the same as the one I had taken from the other soldier,
but the Indians gone had a longer barrel.
Yeah.
One of the Sioux Scalp,
the dead man.
Different ones took his clothing.
I took nothing except the gun.
Continuing on.
Somebody said to me,
look yonder other soldiers,
I saw them on a distant hill down the river and on our same side of it,
the news of them spread quickly among us.
Indians began to ride in that direction
and so they're now going to do again.
This is where I didn't want to try and figure out exactly what bottle,
but yeah,
so there,
there's another portion of the battle taking place.
I know in my head where he's going,
but we'll just say there's,
he sees other soldiers to go after.
I'm pretty sure this is him going after customers.
Yeah.
And as he's going towards this other,
towards this other battle is taking place.
Okay.
He passes through the camp again and he sees his dad and he says,
my father was the only person at our lodge.
I told them of the fight up in the valley.
I told him of having helped in the killing of the enemy,
Indian and some soldiers in the river.
I gave to him the tobacco I'd taken.
I showed him my gun and all the cartridges.
You have been brave.
He cheered me.
You've done enough for the day.
Now you should rest.
No,
I want to go and fight the other soldiers.
I can fight better now with this gun.
You,
your horse is tired.
He argued,
yes,
but I want to ride the other one,
so wooden leg,
he did.
He had a good morning so far,
got after it,
but he sees a fight going on and because he's a warrior,
he says,
Nope,
I'm getting back in the game.
Back to the book.
As we approach the place of battle,
each one chose his own personal course.
All of the Indians had come out on horseback.
Almost all of them.
Dismounted crept along the goalies a foot after the arrival near the soldiers.
I think that's
the reason I,
the reason I highlighted that is because you got people doing decentralized
command.
Oh,
you see where the battle is?
Get there,
right?
You're not,
we don't have to line up.
We don't have to march.
You see the word?
The battle is get there on your own personal course.
Make it happen.
Okay.
Most of the Indians were working around the ridge now occupied by the soldiers.
We were laying down and goalies and behind sage brush hill locks.
The shooting at first was at a distance,
but we kept creeping in closer.
All around the ridge.
Bows and arrows were used more than guns from the hiding places of the Indians.
The arrows could be shot high and long curve to fall upon the soldiers or their
horses.
An Indian using a gun had to jump on up and expose himself long to shoot the
arrows falling upon the horses,
stuck in their backs and caused them to go plunging here and they're knocking
down the soldier.
So this is classic,
you know,
you think that the,
that the,
the rifle is the better weapon,
but the rifle you have to expose yourself to shoot.
Well,
the Indians are just hunkered down behind a knoll or behind some brush or behind
a valley and they're just lobbing like a mortar rounds,
thousands of mortar rounds just hitting into where the soldiers are and the
soldiers can't even do anything to yet.
The long distance fighting was kept up for about an hour and a half.
I believe the Indians all the time could see where the soldiers were because the
white men were mostly on a ridge in their horses were with them,
but the soldiers could not see our warriors has,
they had left their ponies and we're crawling through the gullies and the sage
brush a warrior,
jump up,
shoot,
jerk himself down quickly and then crawl a little forward a little further
forward.
All around the soldier Ridge.
Our men were doing this,
so not many of them got hit by soldier bullets during this time of fighting.
This is beautiful.
This is exactly what you know,
what we teach,
what the whole,
what the what the military teaches.
Individual Movement.
You know,
you shoot,
you get up,
you get back down,
you crawled,
you get up again.
So the enemy might see you right.
When you take a shot,
then you duck,
and then when you pop up again,
you're not in the same place.
So if you were aiming where they work,
they're not there anymore.
This is,
this is beautiful tactics.
In a few minutes,
the warriors were all around these soldiers.
Then lame,
lame white man.
That's an Indian lame white man called out calm.
We can kill all of them.
All around the Indians began jumping up,
running forward,
dodging down,
jumping up again down again all the time towards the soldiers right away.
All the white men went crazy.
Instead of fighting us,
they turn their guns upon themselves almost before we could get to them.
Every one of them was dead.
They killed themselves.
Okay.
The Indians took the guns of these soldiers and use them for shooting at the
soldiers on the high ridge.
I went back and got my horse and rode around beyond the east end of the,
by the time I got there,
all the soldiers were dead.
The Indians told me they'd killed only a few of those men and that the man had
shot each other and shot themselves.
And this is,
this is very controversial.
Oh.
You know,
whether these guys killed themselves and I don't even know if it's that
controversial.
It's like straight up.
Most people don't believe that.
Um,
I don't know.
I don't know what the answer is,
but we know that one thing we do know they're all dead.
Mm hmm.
Back to the book,
I saw one sue walking and I'm sure,
you know what?
I'm sure that somebody that's listening to this is going to give us the full
report.
We'll deal.
Yeah.
And actually I have books.
I have books.
And this is not,
um,
this is not the same account.
Right.
This is different than killing themselves.
So I know that,
but what I'm talking about this book right now,
so I'm going with it.
I saw one sue walking slowly toward the gulch going away from where we're the
soldiers.
He wobbled disley.
As he moved along,
He fell down,
got up,
fell down,
got up again as he passed near to where I was,
I saw that his whole lower jaw was shot away.
The side of him made me sick.
I had to vomit.
I did not know him,
and I did not learn whether he died or not.
Okay?
The shots quit coming from the soldiers.
Warriors who had crept close to them begin to call out that all the white men
were dead.
All the Indians then jumped up and rushed forward.
All the boys and the old men on their horses came tearing into the crowd.
The air was full of smoke and dust.
Everybody was greatly excited.
It looked like thousands of dogs might look if they were mixed together in a
fight.
All of the Indians were saying that these soldiers went so crazy,
they killed themselves.
I do not know.
I could not see them,
but I believe they did so again,
so he doesn't even know what the real deal is there,
but like I said,
what we do know is that not one of them lived.
I took one scalp.
As I went walking and leading my horse among the dead,
I observed one face that interested me.
The dead man had a long beard growing from both sides of his face and extending
several inches below the chin.
He also had a full mustache.
All of the beard hair was of a light yellow color as I now recall it.
Most of the soldiers had beard growing in different lengths,
but this was the longest one I saw among them.
I think the dead man may have been 30 or more years old.
Here is a new kind of scalp.
I said to a companion,
I skinned one side of the face and half of the Chin so as to keep the long
beard.
Yet on the part removed,
I got an Arrow shaft and tied the strange scalp to the end of it.
This I carried in hand as I went looking further,
somebody told me noisy walking was badly wounded.
That was another Indian named noisy walking.
I went to where he was said to be
okay
down in the gulch where the band of soldiers nearest the river had been killed
in the earlier part of the battle.
He was my same age and often we had been companions since our small boyhood
white bowl and important medicine man was his father.
Noisy walking had been hit by three different bullets.
One of them having passed through his body.
He also had some stab wounds in his side.
I asked the young man,
how are you?
He replied,
good,
but he did not look well.
One Young Cheyenne took something from a dead soldier just after all of them had
been killed.
He was puzzled by it.
Some others looked at it.
I was with them.
It was made of white metal and had glass on one side on this side where marks of
some kind while the Cheyenne was looking at it.
He got it up towards his ear.
Then he put it up close.
It's alive.
He said,
others put it to their ears and listened.
I put it to mind.
Tick,
tick,
tick.
It was saying,
we talked about its use.
We generally agreed that it was a soldier,
special medicine.
Many Indians came and wondered about it.
The young man decided to keep it for his own medicine.
So they,
they found a watch on one of the soldiers,
a little windup pocket watch.
And to me this was just a really good example of,
of the,
you know,
the cultural differences.
They didn't,
they'd never seen a watch before and,
and so they were surprised and demon understanding what it was or that it was
not actually alive.
It was just a mechanical watch.
Yeah.
Back to the book,
noisy walking died during the night after the great battle six,
Cheyenne's had been killed.
Another man open belly was badly wounded and was expected to die.
He was about 30 years old,
but he hadn't,
neither wife nor children.
The six dead were lame.
White man,
limber bones,
black bear,
noisy,
barking hump.
Knows when whirlwind.
Yeah.
And then after that battle,
during the afternoon,
it was learned that yet another band of white men were coming up the little big
Horn valley.
All the young men wanted to fight.
A council of chiefs was held.
They decided we should continue in our same course and not fight any soldiers.
If we could get away without doing so,
all of the Indians and got ready to move,
probably a smart move.
So then after that they have,
they go to this area that's called greasy grass and there they have a little,
a little war dance,
a little sort of a,
I guess you'd call it a ceremony or a celebration.
Back to the book.
Charcoal bear on medicine chief brought the buffalo skin from the sacred tp and
put it on top of a pole at the center of our Camp Circle.
We danced around this pole.
No women took part in the dancing.
Many of them had sore legs from morning cuts and when they lose their,
their husband,
they would cut themselves,
are dance,
was not carried very foreign to the night.
It was mostly a short telling of experiencing accounting of cool.
My father told in a few words what his two sons had done when he ended the
telling of my warrior acts,
he said the name of this son of mine,
his wooden leg,
up to this time,
people would still use my boyhood name,
eats from his hand,
but now this old name was entirely gone.
So is after that battle of little big horn is when wooden leg became wooden leg.
Now they proceed and together and all this big mass of tribes and at this point
they're about to separate their tribes and start going in their own directions
and then they get a report.
Soldiers are coming.
The two bands of Indians began to come together again.
The warrior,
the warriors mingled themselves as being one tribe.
The women and children and older men both have both sets of people move together
up the tongue river.
The young men put themselves behind.
They're fleeing people.
Somebody said to me,
they have captured some women.
Your sister is one of them.
My heart jumped when this news came to me.
I latched my horsed into a run toward where it was said they had been captured.
There.
I saw the tracks of soldier horses.
The trail led me to the river of ice on the opposite side of the river.
The west side were soldiers.
They began shooting at me.
I had to get away.
I did not see any of the women,
so I suppose they had been killed.
My heart then became bitter toward these white men.
I hid my horse in the brush at the foot of the ridge where some warriors were on
its top.
I walked up there,
many Indians were hidden behind rocks and we're shooting towards the soldiers.
I chose for myself a place of hiding and did the same.
I had my soldier rifle and plenty of cartridges.
Many soldiers were coming across the ice to fight us,
but we had the advantage because our position was high and on a rocky ridge.
So it's interesting that he,
he's doesn't even become bitter towards the soldiers until they do something to
his sister and then all of a sudden he's bitter towards the white men and it's
also important there.
At the end,
you got to get the high ground,
got to get the high ground.
That's literally the only reason that I put that in there is for a tie.
For those of you out there that are in the military that are fighting get to
high ground,
it gives you a massive advantage over the enemy.
So
after this they kind of settle up the tongue river in there.
I'll go back to book.
We found plenty of buffalo there.
We went on West to the upper little big horn after camping and hunting there,
we went farther to the big horn at the mouth of rotten grass creek.
We did not stay there long.
We returned a little big horn.
Most of the last part of the winter was spent in a camp and this valley all the
time.
During the next few months,
we had good hunting.
Soldiers did not trouble us,
nor did we trouble them.
All the people had good lodges in every way we were living.
Yet according to our customary habits,
we were not bothering any white people.
We did not want to see any of them.
We felt we were on our land.
We had killed only such people as had come for dre had come for driving us away
from it.
So our hearts were clean from any feeling of guilt,
so they're kind of living there,
kind of going back to just live in their own.
They're the way that they were used to live in and this is where you know this
next chapter,
chapter seven is called the surrender of the Cheyanne's.
Just before the grasp began to show itself in the early part of spring,
two visitors arrived at our camp on little big horn.
One of these was our old captured was our captured old woman,
sweet woman.
The other was a half breed sue.
We called white.
Each had a horse to ride and each was leading a pack horse in their packs were
tobacco and other things for gifts to the principal chiefs.
The visitors said they'd been sent out from the soldier fort at the mouth of the
tongue.
River two invite us to come there and surrender peaceably.
They brought us a promise from bear coat,
the soldier chief there,
that we should not be harmed and should be given plenty of food.
So starting to get enticed me starting to get enticed by some by eat,
you know,
basically food tobacco.
Back to the book,
the four chiefs came back to us at this powder river camp.
White Bull was not with them.
They told us he had stayed with the soldiers to scout for them in hunting
Indians.
This news did not please us.
As we looked at it,
the surrendering to the soldiers was good if one felt like doing this,
but an offer to help them to kill friends showed a bad heart.
I was more effected though by other news,
the chiefs broad.
It was Kearny concerning my sister,
crooked nose,
one of the captives when the chiefs were only a part of the first day out and
coming back from the fort,
somebody followed them to tell them about her.
She had been very sad in the heart because of a belief.
She would never again see her people.
She'd felt better when the chiefs came,
but when they went away again,
she fell into a deep grief.
My sorrow was so great.
Her sorrow was so great that she had gotten out or is it hidden?
Six shooter I had given to her and she shot herself dead.
My heart will stop beating.
When I heard about her death this way,
she had been a good sister,
kind to everybody.
Seven Cheyanne's from the agency came to the camp on powder river.
One of them had a teepee lodge,
but no women were with them.
They came only to tell us we ought to surrender at the agency.
They said all the Indians there were being well fed.
We're being well treated in every way.
Nobody was being punished in any manner for past conduct in warfare against the
soldiers.
So they're getting told basically there's another group,
there's they can surrender at the fort,
the army fort or the concern it up the at the Indian agency,
which is also controlled by the soldiers and of course I just read that part
about wooden leg sister committing suicide.
So just a devastating blow to him.
Now as this continues,
the decision gets made by the chiefs to surrender actually at first to find out
a little bit more,
gather some more Intel,
sorry,
little wolf and the other principal chiefs chose to go out to the agency and
then
when they come back,
they say that it's pretty good to go.
And when they hear this,
they hear about the food,
they hear about the whiskey,
they hear about the,
the shelter.
They decide that the main body of the tribe sets off towards the agency to
surrender back to the book.
But not all the Cheyanne's.
We're ready yet to surrender at any place.
14 or 15 men,
six or seven of them having wives or children separated off to go westward.
White Hawk,
a little chief of the elk warriors was with them.
I joined another band still desiring the most freedom we considered to be ours
by right.
34 Cheyanne's made up this pants.
There's a couple little separate groups that break off and decide they're going
to continue pushing.
And as they're doing that,
when they get in these smaller groups,
if you can imagine,
I mean just like,
uh,
any,
any group,
if you break it down enough,
you start to lose your efficiency and that's what happened with these smaller
groups.
They just weren't as efficient anymore because they had less people.
I mean,
you can't count catches many.
You can't work in cooperation to hunt buffalo and so they didn't do well on
their own.
Mm.
Back to the book.
We were having a good many days of hunger.
Our horses had plenty of grass,
but our own ribs were becoming thin.
Our clothing was wearing out and we could not get enough skins to renew them and
keep our beds and our lodges and go to order.
My soldier coat and breaches were gone and my last shirt and cough breaches were
almost in tatters.
The only good article of where I had now was my big white hat I'd had captured
at the Rosebud battle.
A Cheyenne nicknamed Yellow Eagle added himself to us.
He had been at the agency not before,
not long before we decided to have him and white bird go there and spy out the
conditions.
They went in a week or so.
They were back among us.
Good treatment,
plenty of food,
blankets,
everything.
Nobody punished.
They reported.
We started right away for the agency.
So
when they split apart into these smaller groups,
that was definitely problematic.
And now they go from being out there kind of on their own hungry,
running out of food,
don't have good equipment anymore and somebody,
they send somebody to the agency to check it out and they get the report back to
there's plenty of food and blankets and warm and all they're going to do there
is go ahead and give up.
So now they,
they move and they start heading towards the agency and when they get there,
back to the book,
he made us all feel good to see hundreds of Indian lodges.
As we came near to the agency,
we galloped our horses forward.
We cheered and fired gunshots into the air.
Some soldiers came running out of their tents,
but they soon saw we were friendly and only celebrating and notifying our people
we had come.
So here they are,
and they,
and a white man married to Cheyenne woman was acting as an interpreter for the
soldiers.
His name was Roland,
but white hat did not need any interpreter and talking to us.
He could make the sign talk so well after the general handshaking white hat
said,
now you men must give me your guns and your horses.
We were not expecting this,
but we trusted him.
So we began to do as he asked,
I'm telling you gotta be careful in this situation when you started giving up
your guns,
this is not a recommended course of action.
You know,
if you're coming in peace,
why are you not allowed to keep your weapons?
This is not a,
this is not a,
I did not agree with this scenario.
Back to the book,
the,
we had one big chief standing elk who kept saying it would be better if we
should go there.
So they're trying to get them to push towards the south,
like towards Oklahoma.
Would be what would be Oklahoma,
and they're kind of against it.
They don't want to walk anymore and they feel like they,
hey look,
we came here,
we,
we were supposed to be here.
And they're saying,
go,
no,
you know,
we're going to,
we're going to move you guys south.
And they're all saying,
no,
we don't want to.
So that's what's standing elk is talked about.
So standing elk who kept saying it will be better if we should go there.
I think there were not as many as 10 Cheyanne's and our whole tribe who agreed
with him,
there was a feeling that he was talking this way only to make himself a big
Indian among the white people.
The white men chiefs would not talk much to any Cheyenne chief,
but him.
They gave him extra presence and treated him as if he were the only tribe,
the only chief of the tribe.
But he was.
But one of our 40 tribal big chiefs,
one day he went about telling everybody,
all right,
get ready to move.
The soldiers are going to take us from here tomorrow.
Lots of shiny hands were angry.
We'd understood that when we surrendered,
we were to live on our same white river reservation.
We'd given up our guns and our horses and had quit fighting because of this
promise.
Now,
after we had put ourselves at this great disadvantage,
the promise was to be broken,
okay?
But we could not do anything except obey him.
So three sleeps after my small band had come to what we thought was to be our
home.
The whole tribe was on its way to what we now call Oklahoma.
Okay?
So again,
that's why we don't give up our guns.
When you give up your guns,
you give up your strength,
you give up your leverage,
give up your ability to fight.
Okay?
The soldier leader of our movement to the south was known as tall white man.
He was a good man,
always kind to the Indians.
We had to do whatever he said we must do.
But he talked good to our chiefs.
So all of us,
we're pleased to have him guiding us.
You had with him a band of soldiers.
I do not know how many,
but I think there may have been almost a hundred of them are horses that have
been taken away from us at the agency were returned to us.
Still many Cheyanne's did not own any old people who had no animal to ride.
We're provided with them from the soldier herd or very old or sick people were
allowed to ride in the soldier wagons.
Young men who owned no horses had to walk or borrow from friends.
I owned four,
I had three of them loaned out most of the time.
So you guys actually that the treatment at this point by tall white man was
fairly good and it sounds like they kind of got along with the soldiers at this
point.
And here's an example of that.
Soldiers hunted with the Indians.
All the soldiers were friendly and good to us.
They were good shooters and they killed lots of game.
They gave us most of the meat.
I became specifically friendly with two or three of them.
I like to be with them and they appeared to like me.
I went at times to their camp in the evening and visited with them when we were
about halfway along in our journey.
I asked one of them,
let me take your gun tomorrow.
Yes,
you may take it.
He told me.
So I think the reason I,
I wanted to bring that up is when you get,
you know,
soldiers and warriors and you put them together and you get rid of the politics,
guess what?
They get along well,
we liked shooting.
We like haunting.
We're warriors.
We're going to get along.
Hmm.
Kind of like the Germans playing the clean soccer,
playing soccer.
Exactly.
You take the politics out of it and we're just going to,
you know,
have a couple of cigarettes,
maybe a glass of scotch and call it good.
Now when they get down to Oklahoma,
they kind of settle in,
in,
in the south.
And here we go.
Back to the book I learned in the South,
a white man name of long hair.
The soldier,
big chief,
we had killed on the little big horn.
I was told he was called general Custer.
I'd heard his name spoken at the White River Agency,
but not understand clearly who was meant by it.
The southern Cheyanne's knew of him because of his having fought against them
before he had come into our northern country.
They had surrendered to him.
Okay.
After we'd been a year on this reservation,
many of our people began to be asked to be taken back to the north.
There was no game here and we are not allowed to go off the reservation for
hunting and we were not given food is it had been promised we should be given at
times.
Some of our young men would violate the orders and would slip away from the
reservation to get a buffalo or some other animal.
Good to eat.
Some white people said the Indians were killing their cattle.
I do not know.
I did not do this.
I stayed all the time on the reservation,
but if any Indians did kill the white men cattle,
they did so because they were very hungry.
You could not find any wild game.
We ate the beef because it was the best we could get.
We always liked much better than wild game.
There was much sickness among the northern Cheyenne downs to us.
It was a new kind of sickness,
chills and fever and aching of the bones dragged down.
Most of us to thin and weak bodies are people die,
died,
and kept following each another falling one another out of this world.
Finally,
Little Wolf declared that he for one,
was moving back north.
Whether the white people consented or not,
others said they would follow him.
The agent told them that the soldiers would go on the trail,
would kill them.
They were promised more food.
They waited for it,
but it did not come.
More people flocked a little wolf side,
don't knife said he would go too late in the summer.
More than half the tribe started out.
Little Woolf's.
Last message to the was the soldiers may kill all of us,
but they cannot make us stay in this country.
The soldiers went after them.
Other soldiers from other places were sent out to head them off.
The Cheyennes were hunted from all directions.
They were found many times,
but each time the Cheyenne fought off their pursuers and kept moving northward.
Many of our people were killed,
but most of them got back to their old home country and were allowed to stay
there
from the southern Cheyenne.
I learned a great deal about general Custer's dealing with them in that country.
All of them has said he had smoked the peace pipe with them at that time that
they had surrendered to him seven years before he was killed.
According to the custom among us,
this was understood as a promise by him that never again would he fight against
the Cheyanne's.
When they learned that he had been killed by our people in the Sioux,
they considered him as having deserve that kind of death on account of his
failure to keep his piece oath.
I got a wife from the southern Cheyanne's.
She had been a girl at the Cheyenne camp at the wash.
It's a river when Costner and his soldiers came there and killed many Cheyanne's
and burn their lodges in November of night.
Every teen 68 chief black pot was one of the ones killed.
The women and children fled same as ours had done at Poudre river.
It was winter and there was many and that was at that time a deep snow for that
country.
Soldiers Chase the women and children and killed many of them as well as the
men.
My wife at that time,
a girl was barefooted as others were also.
They had been surprised in the early morning she stopped and cut off pieces of
buffalo or buffalo robe to ty about our feet to keep them warm as she ran.
When they got to the camp,
it's of snake Indians farther down the river.
My wife told me she was also with the Cheyanne's when they surrendered to
general Custer in 1869 after he had smoked a pipe with their chiefs.
When they surrendered,
some of the chiefs were put into prison and had chains upon their ankles.
When I heard all of this from my wife as well as from many of the other southern
Cheyanne's,
it seemed the great medicine may have directed Custer to his death as punishment
for having broken his promise to the Cheyennes.
So eventually they do go back north and they reestablish a reservations up in
the north and
eventually wouldn't leg proceeds up there as well.
And when he gets up there,
he seems,
it seems like things are in a pretty bad way.
Back to the book,
the most sorrowful new condition found and coming back to our Cheyenne country
was in the case of little wolf himself,
some white man about the fort were selling or giving whiskey to the Indians.
One night,
little wolf got a bottle of whiskey and right away he drank all of it.
He went into the Fort Traders store and leaned forward upon the counter.
He was quiet,
but he was dizzy and stumbling here and there.
The trader said,
Little Wolf,
you'd better go to your lodge.
But he said,
no,
I want to stay here.
Some Cheyenne men and women were playing cards at a table and the store famished
elk,
a young man,
sergeant of the scouts was with them.
He talked a little wolf,
but the old chief paid no attention to his talk.
Famished Wolf took hold of Little Wolf's arm and said,
calm.
I will help you to get you to your lodge.
He Spoken,
acted respectfully,
but little wolf was angered because of the taking hold of him.
He pulled himself away.
His eyes blazed like fire.
He stood a moment looking at the young man.
Then he said,
I will kill you.
He staggered alone on out from the store,
famished elk return to sit in the card game.
Nobody was expecting any further trouble,
but not long.
Afterward the door was opened in the little wolf,
stumbled into the room.
He straightened himself out,
leveled or rifle and fired.
Famished elk sink down,
dead upon the floor.
The old chief went back to his lodge and told his two wives would,
he had done,
we must go.
He added,
the three of them went out into the darkness of the night.
Soldiers and Cheyenne search for them.
They searched during the next day and the next,
the missing man and his two wives appeared in miles city and sat themselves down
in a place in plain view of the people there,
a captain and some soldiers went to him.
The captain we knew as little chief,
he told little wolf what it was he had done.
He said he further told him,
you are no more a chief of the Cheyanne's.
That is true in just little.
Rolf Wolf agreed.
He was not punished in any other way,
but he further punished himself before he and his wives had left their lodge.
He smashed into pieces.
His medicine pipe.
Our old tribal laws required this.
It was not allowable for him afterward to smoke.
It was allowable for him afterwards to smoke all alone in any small and short
stemmed pipes such as might be made from a deer leg bone,
but he did not do this.
He denied himself all smoking.
He never made any offer even to sit in the company of other Cheyenne Smoking
together.
White men offered him sometimes cigarettes,
but he always refused them.
After a time he learned chew tobacco habit never followed by the old time
Cheyanne's it seemed he did this deliberately for self humiliation.
He never tried to intrude himself on any trouble,
tribal public affairs that people remembered his great services in past times,
but nobody consulted him on tribal matters in present times,
truly in every way.
He was never more uh,
chief among the Cheyennes.
So alcohol not good,
not good for your decision making processes.
Okay.
Back to the book.
When I was 31 years old and 1889,
I enlisted with other Cheyanne's to form a new band of scouts for the soldiers
at Fort Keogh.
Okay.
For a long time we did not do much except drill and work at getting out logs
from the timber and building houses for ourselves.
So he joins the army,
he joins the army,
becomes,
uh,
becomes a scout.
We Cheyenne Scouts and not get into any battle.
At one time we were all dressed and ready,
but the officers made a stop behind the hill while the soldiers went on and
killed many sue at a camp on a little valley.
Just over the hill.
Uh,
sue started that fight by killing an officer who was taking all the guns from
them.
The soldiers began to shoot in many women and children were killed as well.
Yeah.
This trouble was on wounded knee creek
at the time of our advance up the hill,
I was wearing a war bonnet for the first time in any battle.
So he's talking about,
they were present at the,
at the massacre at wounded,
at wounded knee,
which was a horrible massacre committed.
You can hear there was between 150 and 300.
Okay.
Sue were killed by soldiers and new included.
Uh,
probably about half of them were women and children
and
okay.
He later he's talking about,
Some dreams that he has
back to the book.
I believe I slept,
but I'm not sure whether I was sleeping and dreaming or I was only lying there
and thinking I kept my cartridge belt buckled on me and I hugged my rifle to my
body.
It seemed that angry Sioux Indians were all about me.
They were searching for me to kill me.
Okay.
Some of them were striking at me with war clubs and slashing and me with knives.
I heard them calling my name wooden leg.
I jumped up and stood there wide awake.
Okay,
so he's having nightmares here.
He's massacre happens and he feels like obviously subconsciously he's got some
some nightmares about that.
Now back to the story of Little Wolf,
the the chief that that shot the uh,
other Indian at the card game.
Okay.
Back to book.
One day I saw the old man little wolf at the camp.
This is years later.
I said to my wife,
I see little wolf.
He's my relative.
One of his wives is a sister of my father.
I think I ought to invite him to eat at our lodge.
I'm glad to hear you say that.
She answered,
tell him to come now.
Right away.
B,
she began to prepare bread and meat and a coffee.
When I brought little wolf around,
I found he was partly drunk.
He fumbled the food and he sat and ate.
He ate freely as though he were very hungry.
He kept quiet and kept looking downward during all the time.
When he was done eating.
I told him of my sympathy with him in his great trouble.
He then told me all about the affair.
I love the young man and all of his people.
I was crazy when I shot him at this time and the conversation,
Little Wolf was about 70 years old.
This man gave away all of his horses after he'd been pulled out of his position
as our greatest chief.
After that,
all of his traveling was done a foot.
Sometimes you went alone,
sometimes one or both of his wives accompanied him.
They took along whatever packs they could carry and they slept in temporary
shelters or with no shelter.
He went to at times to visit the crows.
He visited also the Arapahos in Wyoming,
walking 200 miles or more back and again,
he died in 1904 at the age of 83 years.
His wives and close friends stood his body upright on a high hill overlooking
the Rosebud valley where many Cheyenne's had their reservation homes.
A great heap of stones was built to enclose him Vuss standing upright.
24 years later,
his bones were brought to the agency cemetery and put into a grave there.
Bird,
the old time Indian story,
white man who lives in New York had a stone put at the head of this agency
grave,
even in the nearest of relatives of even the nearest relatives of famish.
Delk never kept bad hearts against little wolf at different times I've heard
talk of him from Bald Eagle.
A brother of the young man killed Bald Eagle,
said little wolf did not kill my brother.
It was the white man whiskey that did it.
Yeah.
Now we fast forward
30 years after the great battle against costs.
There was a gathering of Indians and white people at little big horn.
The Cheyanne's and some other Indians went with a few soldiers to fort Custer,
not far from the place where the great battle had been.
The soldiers at the fort shook hands with all of us.
We gathered together and some friendly speeches were made by the officers and
Indians.
All I said was a long time ago,
we were enemies.
Today we are friends.
Then going even further into the adult.
Okay.
50 years old now
wooden leg says I was baptized by the priest at tongue river mission when I was
almost 50 years old.
My wife and our two daughters were baptized too.
I think the white people pray to the same great medicine we do in our old
Cheyenne way.
I do not go to church often,
but I do go sometimes.
I think the white church people are good,
but I do not believe all the stories they tell about what happened a long time
ago.
The way they tell us all the good people in the old times were white people.
I'm glad to have the white man churches among us,
but I feel more satisfied when I make my prayers in the way I was taught to make
them
okay.
My heart is much more contented when I sit alone with my medicine pipe and talk
with the great medicine about whatever may be troubling me.
We had good medicine men in the old times.
It may be that they did not know as much about sicknesses.
The white men doctors?
No,
but our doctors knew more about Indians and how to talk to them.
Our people then did not die young as they so much as they do now.
Okay.
Now wouldn't leg had a couple daughters.
Yeah,
and he talks about them here.
The younger daughter fell into an illness when she was about 14 years old.
We expected she would soon be herself again,
but she grew worse.
Instead of better,
she became so weak she could not stay at school any longer.
She continued to go downward after we brought her into our home.
Finally,
her spirit went back to the great medicine.
All of our love was now fixed upon the other daughter.
She advanced to full young womanhood.
She could read the white man books.
She could write letters to our friends far away,
but she too became ill.
Same as her younger sister.
During all of one winner,
she gradually wasted away every afternoon.
Her body burned with fever every night.
Her bed was soaked with sweating.
Every morning she coughed almost a strangling,
neither the medicines of the agency physician nor the prayers of our own
medicine men could help her.
Just when the spring grass was coming up,
she was buried in our mission cemetery,
my heart down to the ground.
I decided then that the white man's school is not good for Indian children.
I think they do not get enough of meat at the boarding school.
I think that they are kept in school too much during the year.
They ought to be out and free to go as they pleased during all of the good
weather of the autumn and the spring.
And the book closes out
okay
in last years of wooden legs life.
And he's,
he's old and he's respected and he's living safely
a reservation
and he says
it is comfortable to live in peace on the reservation.
It is pleasant to be situated where I can sleep soundly every night without fear
that my horses may be stolen or that myself or my friends may be crept upon and
killed.
But I like to think about the old times
when every man had to be brave.
I wish I could live again through some of the past days when it was first
thought of
every prospering Indian.
The first thought of every prospering Indian was to send out the call.
A whole friends come
calm,
calm.
I have plenty of buffalo meat.
I have coffee,
I have sugar,
I have tobacco come friends,
feast and smoke with me,
and I'll tell you
that I miss those days to
win.
Every man had to be brave.
When comfort
was no guarantee,
when life itself wasn't a guarantee,
then I think that is one of the lessons
to be taken
from wooden leg is something you hear me say often is that you have to cherish
it.
Cherish the struggle,
the contest,
the suffering,
the risk.
Don't shy away from it,
but instead,
okay.
Cherish it
in another piece that I find so important,
so reinforcing to what I see in the world is look at how the Cheyanne's were
beaten.
There wasn't,
it wasn't in war.
There wasn't in battle.
The,
they weren't defeated by the white man's guns or the white man's tactics.
No,
they were slowly taking apartment,
convinced,
convinced to take an easier path and enticed by the comfort of the reservations.
We're food and shelter and tobacco.
When alcohol,
we're all readily available.
Yeah.
They weren't defeated in some diff decisive battle by weapons or by war.
They were defeated
and controlled by one tiny,
seemingly insignificant surrender at a time,
giving up their land and then giving up their horses and then giving up their
guns.
Then they were tricked.
They were lied to,
and the word was not kept in.
The promises were not kept,
but they gave up their ability to fight back.
And it's hard to guard against that.
It's hard to even see it happening because it's like trying to watch an hour
hand move.
You don't see it,
you don't see it move,
and then you turn around in this,
this beautiful in this magnificent warrior culture
is relegated to
whiskey and dependency and entrapment on reservations.
And I think that's an important message.
I think that's an important message for our culture,
this culture that we have now,
a culture of creativity and open mindedness and of strength and of individual
freedom.
Okay,
that we need to stay vigilant.
We need to stand guard against small infractions that may seem meaningless and
insignificant,
but that will chip away
at who we are as a people.
Okay,
and as a culture
and the native Americans,
I mean,
we could go on and on about the bravery
that those warriors showed even past this period in World War II.
There's story upon story about the bravery that they showed in the Vietnam War,
native Americans that served with honor and courage,
but we have to learn more than just that,
and I think it's the same thing on an individual level as well
because it's not that,
it's not that we,
as people said,
that we as an individual,
as a person,
it's not that you wake up one day and you decide that's it.
Okay,
I give up.
I'm going to be weak now.
I'm just going to just surrender everything to be comfortable.
We don't do that in one day.
It doesn't happen.
It's not one decision.
It's a slow,
incremental process
that just chips away,
chips away at or wheel and chips away.
In our discipline,
we wake up a little bit later and we miss a workout than we miss another one.
Then we just start to eat,
but we shouldn't eat.
And we start to drink what we shouldn't drink.
And without even realizing it,
one day you wake up and you become something that you never would have allowed.
And instead of
being strong,
you're weak.
And instead of being disciplined,
you are disorganized and you are lost.
And instead of moving forward and progressing,
you are moving backward
and you aren't decaying.
Yeah.
And that happens without us even seeing it.
Well allowed US recognizing it.
So you have to be vigilant.
You have to be on guard,
you have to hold the line even on the seemingly insignificant things,
things that shouldn't matter.
But those things do matter.
And instead of going backward instead of decaying,
get stronger,
get better,
grow and learn and develop and live
in.
Live in such a way
that you don't remember the old days with sorrow,
that they are gone,
but with pride.
Yeah.
And with gratitude that those old days led you to where you are today.
Place of wisdom and a place of knowledge and a place of experience
in a place of peace.
And I certainly hope that
wooden leg found his piece
with the great medicine.
You don't how in,
I don't know if I,
I mean you're probably one of the few people
that I know anyway that probably didn't go through high school and think about
history class.
Think when am I ever going to use,
a lot of us think thought that and like this kind of stuff,
right?
Like actual stuff,
history.
This is history.
This should have been in history class and it probably was.
Yeah.
You had to have learned about the battle of little big horn.
You,
you had to have,
you may not remember it.
I don't remember from high school that was whatever,
40 something,
you're wounded knee rings a bell.
Right.
You know?
Yeah.
So that was probably the attitude for most of us.
Like what are we going to use this?
Why do I gotta know this?
You know,
1776 like why,
why do,
why?
How is this gonna help me in my job that I'm going to be,
you know,
a doctor or whatever.
Even if you had high aspirations.
So this,
that last part you just said,
but that's,
that's why for real.
The what part?
What do you mean?
The whole part?
Yeah,
at the end where you're like,
okay,
look,
and here's what,
how it was explained to me by my mom and dad.
History's important because you have all the people that you learn about all the
events you learn about,
you learn lessons out of it.
Of course,
as a kid you're like,
all right,
well you know,
I'm just memorizing dates and events here.
But they're like,
no,
you learn lessons like history,
you know,
wars,
all the,
this is the,
it's all to like settle problems.
You got to learn lessons from Mr. I'm like,
alright,
I get it.
This,
I think on an,
on a group level you can learn a lot of lessons.
Of course from history.
This on an individual,
individual level,
everybody,
especially now,
Bro,
now it's like was thinking about this today I'm driving home,
went to the pumpkin patch right in the pins and patches.
It's a,
it's,
it's really cool.
It's a,
it was down in Bonita was it wasn't like a built one in a parking lot and then
you go through,
it was like a legit one and I'm hardly anyone there.
And My,
I'll just running around and um,
you know,
my wife comes from the country and stuff so she's like,
see this kind of pumpkin patch is great compared to the ones that built in the
parking lot.
And I'm thinking that's where we are today where,
Oh,
not a pumpkin patch,
let's go build the pumpkin patch.
Like that's how much,
how little really we have to do.
We're building pumpkin patches so you can go experience a pumpkin patch on
pavement.
Yes.
In a parking lot in a boy.
Yeah.
When we're done with this,
you know,
Bill Finger in it,
we get,
you know,
you have shows on TV.
I always harp on reality TV,
but man,
this is the reality
of it,
where we have time now,
the time and the inclination to sit and watch hours of just other people living
there now.
That's embarrassing.
That's where we are today.
I'm not saying we all do it,
but I'm saying we can if we want.
Yeah,
we can if we want.
That's where we are.
Okay,
so consider that.
That's the opposite of this.
That's like basically what you're talking about right here.
Yeah.
Where you're like,
okay,
the more like kind of like,
you didn't really say avoid luxury,
nothing like that.
But basically you're keep keep your capability in check.
You know,
like I don't want to miss the old days when I was capable,
you know,
because I gave it up to be more comfortable.
That's it.
That's the lesson I think that you can learn individually.
Yeah,
no doubt.
And I think even,
you know,
the,
the culture,
we're talking about cultures to cultures of warriors that they know,
they,
they got overrun by the white man,
right?
Overrun by the white man.
Now there was brutal battles and we're going to go,
I mean,
you,
you could spend all day talking about,
but we're talking,
I'm just,
I'm just speaking about one aspect of this.
You had incredible warrior cultures that had lived this way for unknown amount
of time,
thousands of years,
and in what,
50 years or something?
A hundred years.
It was completely different for them.
And Yeah,
and what I'm saying is you think that they got crushed or destroyed or there was
this battle like,
no,
if you,
if you hear that story,
it wasn't a fight to the death.
It was a slow,
just crumbling away of their,
of their culture,
the way they had it.
And you know,
and from a,
from a perspective of,
I mean,
another lesson that can be taken away from this that that's,
you know,
we,
we talk about this all the time.
That was a,
it's,
it's a form of negotiation,
right?
Listen,
Hey,
don't worry about it.
Just come,
come a little bit,
you know,
just move a little bit further down the path,
moving a little bit further down the path,
move a little bit further down the path and um,
yeah,
that's what I,
that's my point is be careful and pay attention to what you're giving up.
Yeah.
From your,
from your individual life and from your culture as a,
as a group,
right.
In America,
I'm speaking now from my culture as an American.
That's our culture.
What are we going to give up?
Where is it going?
That's what we need to look out for.
Because at some point we can look around and it's one thing if we don't have the
culture anymore,
we don't,
we have a different culture.
But the thing that I'm talking about,
it's okay for American culture to morph and to grow.
That's okay.
But what I do,
what we do have to watch out for is if we ever give up the strength to defend
ourselves and say,
you know what?
Okay,
you crossed the line.
Yeah.
And we are not going to do what you're saying right now.
You know,
that's what we need to be careful of.
We can never give up.
You know,
somebody asked me on Twitter the other day and what's,
you know,
in 140 characters,
what should our foreign policy be?
And I did it in one word.
Our foreign policy,
she be strength.
Strength should be our foreign policy.
We should be strong.
And I'm telling you right now,
and we've talked about this before,
when you are strong and you can defend yourself and you know that you can handle
any problem that comes your way,
you're not going to have many problems.
Right.
It's not going to happen.
It's when you're weak,
it's when you let your guard down,
that's when you have problems.
Yeah.
The strength essentially
capable capability.
Right.
That's a,
and I'm not saying,
I'm not talking about the foreign policy thing at all.
Right.
You want to go down that path with me?
No,
I mean not now,
but okay,
so you know like,
like crossfit for example,
right?
Oh yeah.
Okay,
well we'll buy strength.
I don't just mean strength,
like I mean skill.
I mean
the capability is capable because I stand corrected.
Yeah,
no,
I didn't mean to correct.
Of course.
More like that.
You know,
I'm,
I'm contributing,
you know,
we'll say country,
but you know how,
um,
okay,
so I remember when crossfit fit exploded onto the scene and people got really
into it and sometimes people would get criticized.
Like,
man,
you're doing this all this crazy word he used to getting good at working out.
Like you're trying to get into this crazy shape for nothing.
Like what are you training for?
You're not gonna train it for sport.
You just training.
I mean,
I'm sure you could actually,
same could kind of be said about you.
You're waking up every day trading all hard.
Like for what?
And you're like for life,
right?
So you're,
you're training for capability.
I'm capable.
Oh,
are you capable?
And what level of capability do you have?
You know,
so people who've spent like an an this
by no means is any kind of judgment.
But if you've spent your life neglecting your health or your capability,
you know you can be less well off,
you're not going to be very well off.
So with that there is that caution.
Like this is the tale,
a cautionary tale,
one of the many probably over history where if you are capable,
you live,
it doesn't seem like your environment is testing that capability in the Bro
Watch out
man.
Yes,
yes.
Test the capability yourself.
Here's what you got to test the capability yourself.
That's a good thing too.
And the [inaudible] about spending too cause the whole the system and the
system.
But
especially now,
like I said,
like life is luxury right now for us word you can
back in the day you're hunting for food,
you were starvation here it's like too much.
For example,
in one of your examples from before.
So it's like it's luxury.
So even even like con consumption,
right?
What,
like,
what do you spend your money on,
you know,
spend money on entertainment.
Seems not really in line with improving your capability.
You know,
like that's what I remember when we moved,
I was like,
oh I want to get a home gym.
And it was pretty expensive like what I wanted.
But it was easily justifiable.
Absolutely.
Because,
and I wasn't thinking in these specific terms,
but really basically that's what I was thinking like this is going to help me in
life.
Who's going to be for sure helped me be more capable way more.
And I already had a gym membership,
but you want the home gym,
you want the home day.
He can be even more capable overall.
I'm just saying.
So if,
you know,
like a lot of times that alone can justify like certain types of cancer
for sure.
Yeah.
If you're absolutely,
I don't even think when it,
when it comes to me to spit,
making expenditures on things that are gonna make me better.
Yeah.
There's not even like,
I don't hesitate on those things.
I hold the trigger,
I make it happen and play around,
you know,
do not play around.
And I've been known to be pretty tight with my money,
but not when it comes to something that's gonna make me better.
Yeah,
for sure.
man.
Um,
amazing book,
amazing life.
Pick this book up on amazon.com the book is called wooden leg,
a warrior who fought Custer.
Maybe later we'll do some more.
Maybe we'll do,
do the other side of this battle and maybe get a little bit more into the
battle.
And like I said,
there's plenty of lessons learned from Custer.
There's plenty of lessons learned there and there's a lot of controversy around
it.
And that's what I tried to avoid.
The controversy.
I've tried to stick with just what's being said by wooden leg himself.
There's a lot of controversy about this battle and who did what and who is to
blame and what mistakes were made.
And they're all what I take from all of those things.
I'll learn from all of them.
I'll learn from every theory.
I'll learn from all of,
that's my goal,
but we'll definitely get into that.
Um,
this book is just a great read.
The more you can fill your head up with different perspectives and the more you
can pay attention to the native American and learn more about their culture.
Awesome culture,
worry your culture.
Yes.
A warrior culture.
Love that.
And like I said,
uh,
you know,
serve with honor in all of our wars here,
which is,
you know,
we should probably do a whole podcast about,
about native Americans fighting in World War Two and Vietnam and in the current
conflicts we have.
So you can pick that up on Amazon,
on the interwebs,
and if you want to help the podcast,
you can actually do little click through of Amazon.
Yeah,
I was gonna say,
I'll put that book link on the website,
click on,
it'll take you right to the book.
And
as far as Amazon goes,
in general,
there's a click through on the website,
so,
so it doesn't matter what you're going to buy,
correct.
The front of Amazon.
If you want to support the podcast,
you know,
that's essentially what we're going to invest three to five seconds opening that
page and clicking through.
Yeah.
You want to support the podcast.
That's a great way to know that it doesn't cost me anything.
Yeah.
Getting in the game,
making yourself us,
everyone really more capable.
Yes.
Let's improve knowledge,
capabilities,
all that stuff.
Yeah.
Click through Amazon.
Boom.
Um,
go to the website,
click through and save it to your favorites.
It's a little trick,
little efficient trick support,
um,
actively,
passively,
aggressively,
aggressively.
I'm also speaking of making yourself capable supplementation.
Um,
man,
I still haven't gotten a Krill oil yet.
I'll make that order tonight.
That krill oil is no longer on me.
Yeah.
It's on union.
We,
you know,
we took the steps.
Yeah.
We're doing it.
It was always on me.
Let's face it.
It's fun to put it on your bed.
Nonetheless.
Krill oil is,
would you say that's the main one,
man?
Um,
I've been,
I've been on Trello for a long time and I dig it.
Yeah.
There it is.
A krill oil warrior bars.
These are just ones I'm recommending.
Just go to on it on it.com/ [inaudible] that's for 10% off.
But if you didn't know what on it is,
it's,
it's just the best supplements.
We'll just say that
you have some other cool stuff on there too.
But anyway,
indeed,
that's the one dope.
I think that's some new stuff coming out to,
oh,
we'll talk about that next time.
I got to do an evaluation on that one.
Um,
but yeah,
on it is dope.
Um,
and of course subscribe to the podcast on iTunes if you haven't already.
Yep,
that's a good one.
And tell your friend.
Yeah,
tell your friend and here's the tell all your friends,
both of them.
Yeah.
To subscribe to the podcast.
Here's the,
here's the,
it's,
I mean,
I guess it's kind of obvious for us to say,
hey,
tell your friends about our podcasts.
You know,
that makes sense.
But when you tell your friends about like,
okay,
so I have a friend who has a friend,
our friends,
two of them,
they listen to his podcast.
[inaudible].
We knew them for a long time.
They listened and they tell their other friends,
I didn't know this,
but I see on Facebook.
Thank you for telling me about Jocko podcasts.
I,
you know all this stuff.
So these were people that know us but didn't know about the fire gas.
No.
To Bia will.
No,
no,
no.
Two people that knew us news podcast.
I'd be apparently had told some people he was God and I'm officially,
here's the thing,
the more people who act like I don't take anything.
You talk about extreme ownership,
we'll say anybody book by the way.
Good,
good.
But just the concept of extreme ownership.
You get somebody implementing extreme ownership by a factor of 10% in their life
and they're in your life.
That's an improved life.
That is an improved life.
That's why you,
I would say that's that reason alone is a good reason until someone about the
podcasts.
Yeah.
No,
I mean I hear from people that say the podcast has helped them out greatly,
which is the best.
That's why we're sitting here.
Right.
Cause if all,
if I didn't hear that from anybody,
if we got no feedback,
maybe we wouldn't be doing the podcast right now.
Maybe we wouldn't have to learn about wooden leg tonight.
Yup.
Yeah.
Okay.
So yeah,
tell your friends about the podcast.
Yeah.
Get them in the game for sure.
And tell him about that youtube channel.
The youtube right.
Youtube channel channel's good ankle,
putting up videos almost on a daily rate right now.
Oh wait,
no we don't.
I'm working on a good one.
It's different.
Oh Yay.
I'll tell,
I'll let you know.
I'll see if I can't get it up in the next week or so,
but it'd be,
it'd be good.
Um,
and yes,
I do promise I'll put more videos on there,
but some,
yeah,
you heard that folks above and beyond just the podcast,
I promise
you go to vague promise by the way,
for more videos on
youtube videos and of course
if you're in to tee shirts,
go to Jacklyn store
or rash gardens.
Here's the thing about the rash guard.
I'm not a scientist officially,
but you know,
the 19% improvement of performance,
if you,
if you were the rash guard that,
that we um,
it's starting to look like that is factual.
Yeah.
So,
um,
what do you call it?
Not Proven,
but what do you call it?
Confirmed.
Confirmed,
yeah.
UFC fighter nine year veteran UFC fighter currently fighting in the UFC.
Confirmed it.
Confirmed.
Can Tell Bro.
If anyone can tell,
he can tell measurable scientific.
It's scientific.
Cool.
Why don't you say his name?
Because while I'm saying this,
I'm constantly,
should I say my name is Cole Miller?
Yeah,
we know who it is,
man.
Cole Miller did confirm that his Jujitsu was 19% 19% on the mat confirmed.
Confer it.
Yeah.
And again,
that's,
you know,
if you were going to be doing some kind of a scientific experiment,
you'd want some kind of a doctor.
Yes.
You know,
somebody with a phd,
some of them expert.
You got your expert right there.
Nope.
There you go.
Got Cole Miller sick Jujitsu by the way.
Yeah,
he's,
he sees it.
He feels 19%.
Yup.
Proof he's training with.
He was trained with Rowen.
Yeah.
There's a few people I had trained with that guy.
Why train with him one time and that and how Atlanta,
yeah.
Yeah.
That was like the first time I ever went into a place and I walked in,
I was like,
hey man,
I just want to train.
And he looks at ou rowing Cordy Arrow I think.
And um,
he's in UFC too,
but I shook his hand and this was like 10 years ago or something.
And I shook his hand,
was like,
hey man,
good to meet you.
I'm just here to train.
Can I train on your mats?
And he's like,
yeah,
are you a black belt?
He asked me that and I was like,
yeah,
I am.
And I dunno how he could tell.
He was like,
are you a black belt?
I said,
yeah man,
let's do this.
But he's an awesome guy.
Two minutes.
Super,
Super Nice Guy.
But,
um,
hopefully maybe we need to get him a rash guard too.
And that's not just for Jujitsu,
that's for,
um,
you know,
whatever.
Any physical activity that you need.
Some,
what do you call it?
Range of motion did that.
If that means something to you,
get the rash guard.
It looks dope too.
For people who have a certain level of aesthetic standard.
For those of you that care about that kind of stuff,
not,
I know.
Yeah.
You know you're here to win.
I dig it.
I dig it,
man.
I dig it and respect for that,
but in the event of you caring what you look like,
we've got many,
many compliments on the look of the rash guard,
so just look at it Jocko.
store.com you can look at the rash guard.
Look at the shirts if you like.
I'm going to get one.
You can support that way.
Yeah,
that's a good one.
The game,
you don't need to donate money.
Just look at them.
If you like them,
go ahead.
Get One.
There you go.
If you get when you got to buy one,
of course,
but I'm just saying,
I'm not saying,
Hey,
go buy this shirt.
I'm saying check it out.
Look at it.
If you like how they looked,
then boom.
If you like what they say.
How they make you feel bad.
Go ahead and do that.
Or if you just straight up need 19% improvement in your Jujitsu game to just get
one more of you just need a tee shirt.
But that's true.
Oh we have hoodies too,
by the way.
Coming out.
One,
two weeks,
two more weeks.
One week,
whatever.
I'm running late.
It was a good little hoodies.
Alright.
Yeah.
Some patches coming out to some velcro this.
Yeah,
there's some good stuff on that.
Check it out if you'd like.
And we might have some teeth.
We do have,
we do have Jocko white tea and I'm gonna tell you we didn't expect Jocko white
tea to sell like crazy.
Oh,
but it,
it's all you guys all that are listening to this.
You guys got after it and all the white tea is gone.
Luckily I apologize for that number one.
And you know what?
They just took it completely off of Amazon.
They pulled it down.
Yeah,
I just went to,
cause I was gonna I was going to tweet out some of the awesome reviews that it
got.
Sorry.
Like people that are now dead lifting 8,000 pounds,
by the way.
No,
it's a fact.
Guy Review,
read his,
his dead lift went from four oh five 405 pounds to 8,000 pounds with Jocko white
tea.
So there you have it.
That's worth it in its own right.
So you already say on it supplementation as good.
I don't see if uh,
you know,
a 7,500 pound improvement.
So,
uh,
yeah,
so the Jocko white tea is sold out right now,
but well,
there's more common and depending on when you're listening this,
I'm,
this is what,
what is today?
October 15th?
Yes,
it's October 15th.
So right now it's sold out.
It will be back in full stock.
And not only do we have the tin,
the deluxe 10 that you can buy,
but in the F in,
you're going to also be able to buy a reload.
Just a box with a hundred a hundred count in there.
And some people,
someone wrote a bad review on Amazon good.
And they said,
hey,
your price is too high,
Bro.
I love,
I love the podcast,
but you can't sell me this Jocko white tea for this amount of money.
That's not cool.
And so I talked to my tea people.
Sure.
And I said,
t people,
Emily are our price is too high,
what are we going to do about this?
And she said,
well your price is high because you wanted to get this special hardcore 10 to
serve it in.
And I was like,
well yeah,
because we make,
you know,
we,
we believe in quality,
right?
Sure.
And so we want to have something that is tough.
So we got the tin and she said,
well that Tim costs a bunch of money to make and get sent over here and all this
other stuff.
And I said,
okay,
well how can we make it cheaper?
So we got a box with a hundred in it up the volume,
lower the price.
So now no,
no one's gonna be able to complain about the price,
cause he's gonna be on a par with any other white tea except for it's gonna make
you be able to deadlift 8,000 pounds.
Yeah,
that's a window.
Which is definitely worth it.
I pay,
I pay premium price for that so it's good to go and yeah,
so check out the Jocko white tea and it's uh,
every,
it's,
it did sell out and reading it sold out is because people were buying it.
They bought one and then they bought five more.
It could taste so good and people aren't drinking it pre Jujitsu,
drinking it in the morning,
drinking it before a test.
They're just drinking it all the time.
It just tastes good.
It replaces every other substance you need to drink.
Pretty soon,
very soon you're going,
going out to a club and there's people going to be like,
oh good,
I get you a drink.
Certain he'd be like,
yeah,
I'll take a Jocko white teeth.
They're going to have it on tap.
Interesting that you called the tin.
Uh,
what'd you call it?
DELAC or
luxury.
What did you call,
what you call it?
Something terrible,
I think you said like luxury or something premium?
Nah,
he said something luxury.
I don't know.
Something like that.
Nonetheless.
And we'll play back the tape nonetheless.
This is like,
this is like a bunker more.
It's not luxury.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Well we don't,
we,
we don't make things well haul.
It reinforced,
reinforced,
and what's cool is guess what holds the pen on the pans on my desk now.
Yeah.
One of these,
guess what it all means?
Bunch of nails out my garage.
One of these ships that is hard grammar.
I told you the other band,
like things that have dual purpose,
dual purpose.
I'm going to do something else with it.
Yeah,
there you go.
There's a little book you can get.
It's called extreme ownership.
It's about combat leadership.
If you like the podcast,
check out the book and also you can check out the audio book that Leif Babin who
wrote the book with me.
You.
We read it.
So it's just more of us talking.
Check it out.
That's extreme ownership.
And also of course,
if you feel like you want to keep talking to Echo Charles and I,
you believe it or not,
you can just do it.
You can talk to us.
We're there and we're on the interwebs.
And if you're on the inner webs and we're on the interwebs,
that means we can communicate a little thing called Twitter on Twitter.
Echo is at Echo Charles.
I am at Jocko Willink.
And remember when I said I wasn't going to back off Twitter,
I've been holding the line on Twitter.
I'm ridiculous.
But I have just Cameron,
when I get what I do is when I travel,
when I travel,
I got to sit in an airport.
No,
I'm not going to,
I don't walk around in circles.
I don't,
I don't watch movies.
No.
I either read for the podcast or a hammer Twitter.
So that's what's going on.
It's good to do for obviously for obvious reasons,
but it,
it kind of keeps you informed,
you know,
how like,
oh,
it's getting too,
too many.
Um,
you know,
a lot of people follow you,
so if there,
if you get a certain number of people falling,
you can't respond to everything and you can't read.
So a lot of,
a lot of times people will be like,
Hey,
let me hire someone to do that.
You know,
or,
or it,
hey,
you know,
I'm not going to spend more time on their whatever cause I'm too busy.
So instead of just maybe you know,
a little,
they'll just be completely not shit on it,
you know?
Yeah.
They'll post stuff and then just kind of be it.
That'll be it.
But for a year you're in touch now.
You know what's going on.
Yeah.
And I'd get a lot of good feedback and a lot of good questions.
Got a lot of good questions and so that's worth it.
So if you want it that,
yeah.
Twitter,
Instagram and Facebook,
we're both on there as well.
And that is kind of where we're at with this whole gig now.
Okay.
I guess to close it out tonight,
since we don't have time for questions.
MMM.
You know,
I just want to say thanks to everybody listening.
Thanks for everybody.
All the feedback that you're giving me.
Hey,
I'm hearing so much from first of all military guys,
military service members that are out getting after it.
Guys overseas right now that are crushing the enemy.
Godspeed.
Keep getting after it.
Stay aggressive.
Absolutely.
Stay safe.
Two police officers,
which I hear a ton from back here,
you guys,
thanks for what you do.
Thanks for keeping us safe.
I can't even imagine having that job to be honest with you.
I can't imagine having that job.
I don't have the temperament for that job.
It's not.
It's not for me.
And for those of you that do that job,
stay strong.
I know it's hard times right now.
A lot of risk out there.
A lot of aggressiveness of you guys are extremely precarious position every
single day by the way.
Every single call,
every single moment.
So
thank you for what you do.
Firefighters,
of course,
same thing you guys getting after it and just running towards fire,
right?
That's overcoming an instinct.
That's what you do for a living.
So thank you for what you do.
Then of course we have all the workforce out there that is building and creating
things and making things happen and you are grinding and you building at your
world and your building our world.
And so thank you for doing that.
And of course,
and most important as you roll through and as you continue,
think about wooden leg,
think about living hard,
think about holding the line,
think about being vigilant
and stay,
stay uncomfortable,
stay true,
and stay forward forward of the decay.
And you do that
by getting out there,
getting after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.